ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD
THERE ARE SO GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ ROVE HERTZBERG HILL
HUESO- TADO. JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MONNING MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO RALPH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN I'M BURKE
Y. CASKEY WIENER WILK. MEMBERS
OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE REAL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE LEFT IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR DORADO. AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY. SENATOR MELENDEZ.
SENATOR RUSSELL THANK YOU. WHEN
YOU GO OUT AND SEE THE HALF
EMPTY STREETS THE EMPTY
STADIUMS THE SHATTERED
STOREFRONTS THE PEOPLE WEARING
MASKS DON'T SAY TO YOURSELF IT
LOOKS LIKE THE END OF THE WORLD.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING. LOVE IN
ACTION. WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN
THAT NEGATIVE SPACE IS HOW MUCH
WE DO CARE FOR EACH OTHER FOR
GRANDPARENTS FOR IMMUNO
COMPROMISED BROTHERS AND
SISTERS FOR OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND HEALTH CARE
PUBLIC SAFETY FOOD PROVISION
SANITATION FOR PEOPLE WE WILL
NEVER MEET. PEOPLE HAVE LOST
JOBS OVER THE COLBERT NINETEEN
VIRUS SOME HAVE LOST THEIR
BUSINESSES AND MANY HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES. ALL THE MORE
REASON TO TAKE A MOMENT WHEN
YOU'RE OUT ON YOUR WALK OR ON
YOUR WAY TO THE STORE OR JUST
WATCHING THE NEWS. TO LOOK INTO
THE EMPTINESS AND MARVEL AT ALL
THAT LOVE. THIS IS FILL YOU AND
SUSTAIN YOU. IT IS NOT THE END
OF THE WORLD IT IS THE MOST
REMARKABLE ACT OF GLOBAL
SOLIDARITY WE MAY EVER
WITNESSED IN OUR LIFETIMES.
GRACIOUS GOD HELP WAS TO
PRESERVE THEIR IN OUR CARE FOR
ONE ANOTHER FOR THE GOOD OFALL
HUMANKIND. A MAN. REASONS TO
BUY THREE DAYS OF AMERICA AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOUR YEAH.
YEAH IT WAS. MEN ARE RIGHT
PRIVILEGES FROM OF THE FLOOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
PORTS OF COMMITTEES BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS WERE
PASSING ON THAT AT THIS POINT.
MOVING TO CONSIDERATION. OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE HAVE SECOND
READING. ITEMS ONE THROUGH
FIFTEEN MADAM SECRETARY. SENATE
BILL. SEVEN THREE SEVEN NINETY
FIVE. THREE. 852-855-8788.
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT NINETY NINE
NINE OH EIGHT NINE TWELVE AT
NINE FIFTEEN SECOND READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ. GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS CENTER WORKER YOU
PREPARED. WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE IS A CONFIRMATION OF STEEP
GARDEN IS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES MR
GUARD HAS OVER THIRTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN MANAGEMENT
CONSULTING IN PRIVATE INDUSTRY
PRIMARILY IN THE TECH SECTOR HE
WAS APPROVED ON A BIPARTISAN
VOTE IN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE THIRTY JUNE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER ACTION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT. SEEN
HEARING NINE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES I
TELL FIVE FOR JUST I BRADFORD I
HAVE I AT ALL. NINE HI DOLLY. I
DODD. I TO RUSSELL. I GALGIANI
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I
MITCHELL I MONNING I MORE LOCK
I MORRELL. I NIELSEN I PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO HI ROSS. I REVIEW. I
SKINNER. I STERN HI AMBER RIGHT
I LIKE HOW SKI HI WIENER. I
WILK I. SIR WHAT MOVES THE CALL.
SIX ITEMS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY SIX IN THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE LINE TO RICHARDSON AS A
SECRETARY THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT- MISS RICHARDSON
OWN YOUR OWN CONSULTING COMPANY
AND PRIOR TO THAT SHE SERVED
FOR FIVE YEARS AS CHIEF DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT COVERED
CALIFORNIA. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS VOTE IN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON THE ELEVENTH
OF JUNE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OF IT
ON THIS ITEM CENTER BACK. THANK
YOU- THIS PRESIDENTE SENATORS I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF YOLANDA
RICHARDS AND I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HER AS
SHE WHEN SHE WORKED. WAS CHIEF
DEBBIE'S EXACT A COVER
CALIFORNIA SHE IS SOMEONE WHO
HAS SPENT- IS VERY
COLLABORATIVE IT AND- WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO PARTNER WITH-
THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE LEGISLATURE SO I
TO STAND TO URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
HER CONFIRMATION THANK YOU.
THANK FOR THE DISCUSS DEBATE ON
THE- IN SEEN NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES I TELL I FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI CUT BY ADAM. I
CHIANG HI DOLLY I DODD I
TORONTO I GALGIANI I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO. I
TADA I JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ I MITCHELL.
MONNING I MORE LOCK AYE MORALE.
I NIELSEN I CAN FIVE PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN. I AM VERY I LIKE HOW SKI.
FIVE WIENER. FIVE WILK HI.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MITCHELL HI.
HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED EXCEPT
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF LARA'S CASTER
REPAIRS SS CHERRY OF THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY MISS CHARACTER
ROMERO'S WAS PRESIDENT THE
UNIVERSITY HEALTH SYSTEMS
FOUNDATION SINCE. TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND PRINCIPAL DEPUTY
ASSISTANT AT THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT BUT- IN TWENTY SIX.
IT WAS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
VOTE IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE
LEVIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER SENATOR RUBIO. I JUST
WANNA RISE ENTHUSIASTICALLY IN
SUPPORT OF NEW DEATH AND CASTRO
I JUST WANT TO SAY BESIDES THE
WEALTH OF IN DEPTH OF
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE TO THE
TABLE SHE ALSO HAPPENS TO BE
OUR WELL- EIGHTY EIGHT. TINA
WHO ALSO PARTICIPATES IN
SUPPORT TO OTHER WOMEN AND TELL
AGAIN JUST ONE AT MY VOICE THAT
I ENTHUSIASTICALLY WOULD LIKE
TO ADD TO HONOR HER BY JUST-
STATING THAT HE'S DONE MUCH I
WANT TO ORDER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY FOR THE COMMISSIONERS
RATE. HE HEARINGS NINE BUT I'M
SECTOR CALL THE- OUR- I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES I
FELL I FOR JUST. I BRADFORD I
HAVE A YELLOW I CHIANG I DALLY.
I DODD. I THERE ARE SO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG I HILL BY WITH
SO. HI TADO FIVE JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MITCHELL. I MONNING
FIVE MORE LOCK AYE MORALE I
NIELSEN. I PAN I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. STERN
HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT I LIKE
HOW SKI. I WIENER. I WILK HI.
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROWTH I
SKINNER. OUR IS THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THE OINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
LOOK TO CALL ON- ON ITEM FILE
ITEM FIFTY FIVE. MAN MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CABALLERO FIVE
GROWTH I. PRICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO SENATE
THIRD READING. WE'RE STARTING
OFF WITH FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR.
CENTER BELLI IS EITHER YOU'RE
PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR. HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RE SENATE BILL NINE
FORTY BY SENATOR VAL AN ACT
RELATING TO LOOK LAND USE
SENATOR BILL. ALL THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL- THANK YOU-
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY
I PRESENT- THIS BILL WHICH
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE TO MAKE SMART ZONING
UPDATES. THAT WILL PROTECT OUR
OPEN SPACE AND REDUCE SPRAWL.
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE IS WORKING
ON AN AGGRESSIVE PLANT UPDATED
ZONING ORDINANCES TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF INFILL HOUSING.
IN THE URBAN CORE AREAS AROUND
TRANSIT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
RECENT STATE LAW CHANGES- WHILE
THE WHOLE STATE IS A PROBABLY
FOCUS ON INCREASING ITS HOUSING
PRODUCTION. WE MUST DO SO
RESPONSIBILITY. SAN JOSE IS IN
THE PROCESS OF REZONING OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRES OF OPEN
SPACE THAT IS CURRENTLY IN
CORRECTLY ZONE. THE CITY WILL
INCREASE ZONING DENSITY AND
URBAN CORNER TRANSIT IN ORDER
TO STAY IN COMPLIANCE WITH
OTHER STATE LAWS AND MEET THE
DEADLINES THE CITY NEEDS
AUTHORIZATION TO GET THIS WORK
DONE. THIS NEXT YEAR. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES SAN JOSE TO OBSERVE
OWN HOUSING SITES PRO ACTIVELY.
AND THEN USE THE DOWNS OWN
CAPACITY TO PROTECT OPEN SPACE
LAND BY DOWNLOADING SITES
OUTSIDE THE URBAN AREA. ARE WE
CRAFTED THIS BILL TO ENSURE
THERE'S NO NET LOSS IN ZONING
AND NO DO YOU NEED A DECREASE
IN THE HOUSING CAPACITY THE
BILL. ALLOWS SAN JOSE TO
PROMOTE SMART ANTI SPRAWL
DEVELOPMENT. WHILE PRESERVING
OPEN SPACE AND I RECOUP
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEMS OF WAR
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AT I RISE IN SUPPORT S.
B. NINE FORTY AND JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR FINDING
IS FLEXIBILITY IN A SOLUTION
AND IT MAY BE- A MODEL WORTH
CONSIDERING IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE WHERE WE FACE
SIMILAR- BALANCING NEEDS
BETWEEN OUR OPEN SPACE. AND
FIRE RISK ISSUES IN THE NEED TO
THE DEMANDS OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS THAT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR. ANY FURTHER.
OR THE RAID ON THE SIDE OF.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER TO GO
TO A CLOSE TONIGHT ABOUT. AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES I TELL FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM I
CHIANG. I DALLY I DODD. I
TORONTO I GALGIANI HI GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL I HUESO I TADO I
JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MITCHELL
I MONEY. I MORE LOCK. AROUND
NIELSEN I CAN I PORTANTINO FIVE
ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI
STERN. FIVE NUMBER NINE I LIKE
HOW STEVE. I WIENER I WILL HI.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. FOR JUST. I GROWTH I
MORE LOCK. MORALE. ICE THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO FALL
ITEM SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR
DAUGHTER YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
ITEM. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT
RELATING TO INSURANCE CENTER
DOG WHEN YOU'RE READY SLOW DOWN
DON'T HURT YOURSELF. I DID.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON YEAR
ROUND FIRE STE- SEASONS IN THE
DEVASTATING FIRES OF RECENT
YEARS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED
FOR INCREASED CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS REGARDING
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY INSURANCE
SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF INSURED LOSSES AFTER
DECLARE DISASTERS IN SEVERAL
IMPORTANT WAYS WHAT INSURANCE
SUFFERED A TOTAL LOSS AFTER
DECLARED DISASTER THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE INSURERS TO MAKE
AN IMMEDIATE AT THE- BUT FOR A
CHANCE. HE HAD L. ET AT LEAST
25% OF AN INSURED'S CONTENTS
POLICY LIMIT IT FOR ME THEIR
HOUSE THE ONLY WITHOUT
SUBMITTING A LENGTHY IN A
MASSIVE INVENTORY OF ONE'S
BELONGINGS IT ALSO PROVIDES A
SIXTY DAY GRACE PERIOD FOR
PREMIUM PAYMENT IN THE EVENT OF
A STATE OF EMERGENCY. BUT FOR A
CLARIFIED. WHEN AN INSURED
CHOOSES TO PURCHASE A HOME
RATHER THAN REBUILD THAT THE
INSURER CANNOT DEDUCT THE LAND
VALUE FOR THE PRICE OF THE NEW
HOME FROM THE AMOUNT THAT THEY
PAY THE INSURER. PROVIDING
THESE ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS
FOR CONSUMERS OF RESIDENTIAL GE
INSURANCE PROPERTIES WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RELIEF AND
SAFEGUARDS TO INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I. BUT- ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION IN THE VERY. CENTER
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT- I AM PLEASED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF A SEVENTY
TWO I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SEE THAT THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
NAPA. FOR HIS HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE LOSING'S ONE HOME OR
BUSINESS TO A FIRE IS ONE OF
THE WORST EXPERIENCES A PERSON
OR A FAMILY COULD LIVE THROUGH.
AN FORTUNATELY AS WE HAVE ALL
SEEN TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE EXPERIENCES
LOS OVER THE PAST MANY YEARS IT
IS CRITICAL MEASURES LIKE THIS
ARE CODIFIED SO THOSE WHO
SUFFER LOSSES FOLLOWING A
DISASTER IN THE FUTURE. DO NOT
HAVE TO FIGHT THE SAME BATTLE
SAYS SO MANY FIGHT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND DO
THINK A GOOD SENATE FROM NEVER.
WORK THANK YOU TENER GIRL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR. WITHOUT
THE TAKE QUESTION YES AS THANK
YOU SIR JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY A
AND JUST FOR MY OWN BENEFIT I
GUESS I CAN MAKE A DECISION ON
THE BILL- AND- USUALLY PURCHASE
A POLICY FOR TWELVE MONTHS A
ONE YEAR TIME PERIOD AND THAT'S
YOUR POLICY FOR THE YEAR FOR
YOUR HOMEOWNERS OR FOR YOUR
HOME CALL YOUR HOME OR ITS
POLICY. DOES THIS BILL
AUTOMATICALLY SEND THOSE
POLICIES FOR THIRTY SIX MONTHS
WILL PREMIUM BE INVOLVED FOR
THE ADDITIONAL TIME FRAME OTHER
THAN THE TWELVE MONTHS I'M JUST
CARE ABOUT THAT. SIR DOLLARS
LIKE TO RESPOND TO JUST
SUMMARIZE THAT QUESTION AGAIN
AND A YEAR TO TALK ABOUT AN
EXTENSION OF THE OF THE POLICY.
YES SIR. SAID I DON'T REALLY
GET A POLICY FOR TWELVE MONTHS
ON YOUR HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE.
UNDERSTANDING IS BASED ON THE
DOCK THE PAPER THAT I HAVE A
FRIEND IN ME IS THE D. BILL
WOULD INCREASE IT FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY SIX MEN. OR
IS IT SOMETHING SEPARATE WELL
MY GUESS I'M LOOKING AT RIGHT
NOW IS THE PREMIUM THE PREMIUM
WOULD BE THE PREMIUM THAT THEY
HAD BEFORE YOUR PRIOR TO IN THE
ORIGINAL POLICY OKAY THANK YOU
SIR. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS COURSE ON THE
SIDE ON. XENON SENATOR DODD
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. YES MISTER
PRESIDENT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL- FOR A FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT REASONS- NOT
WITHSTANDING THE FACT THAT WHEN
YOU'VE LOST EVERYTHING. IN A IN
A FIRE YOU'RE STARTING ALL OVER
HIM WE'VE WE'VE LOOKED AT A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT INSTANCES
IN THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FIRES IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRES AND WE BELIEVE
THIS IS A GOOD COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT THAT REALLY
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN-
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO DO
COULD SOON. AND THAT ALSO
LISTENING TO APPEARANCE COMPANY
AND WHAT THEIR CONSPIRED IN THE
GIVE TAKE WHEN AND TO ALL THAT
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
BOTH. THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. BELL FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I CHIANG.
DALLY DODD I THERE ARE SO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL I WAS
SO WELL I TADO I JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL I MONNING
BY MORE LOCK NO MORALE.NO
NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER I Y. CASKEY I
WIENER I WILK. I'M SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EIGHT GORGEOUS. CHIANG DALLY.
GROWTH MELENDEZ. NIELSEN WILK
WHEN. HI IS TWENTY NINE KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX
INTERJECTION ARE YOU PREPARED
FOODS ARE. I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
IT. SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE BY SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT
RELATING TO JURIES. SYNERGY
ACTION THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THIS MEASURE IT EXTENDS THE
SUNSET DATE ON A LAW THAT
REDUCES THE NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES AFFORDED
IN MISDEMEANOR TRIALS
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES AND ALLOW
ONE ATTORNEY TO DISMISS A JUROR
WITHOUT GIVING ANY REASON. THE
CALIFORNIA LAW LIMITS NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES A TWO SIX
IN CRIMINAL TRIALS IN FELONY
AND MISDEMEANOR TRIALS IN
FELONIES IT'S A LARGER NUMBER
AND OF COURSE IN DEATH PENALTY
CASES OF TWICE THAT NUMBER. THE
BILL ARE WILL ALLOW AN
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET FOR
THREE YEARS IT IS SPONSORING BY
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES.
SUPPORTED BY BOTH THE
ASSOCIATION OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL OFFICERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA LET JUDGES
ASSOCIATION ARE YOU STILL THERE
TRONG THAT THE REDUCE NUMBER
BRENT CHALLENGES FOR ALL TO
MORE. YOU WERE JURORS I NEED TO
BE SUMMONED TO SERVE IN A JURY
POOL WHEN THE NUMBER OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES
DECREASES. NOW LET US LOOK AT
THE WORLD WE LIVE IN TODAY.
WHERE THE COURTS HAVE SUSPENDED
CRIMINAL TRIALS IN FACT ALL
TRIALS AND WHEN IT'S DIFFICULT
TO GET JURORS. IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO COME IN TO ANSWER
A JURY SUMMONS THE JURY ROOMS
ARE SMALL. ARE THEY ARE USUALLY
FILLED TO THE BRIM WITH PEOPLE
SO THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING WOULD
NOT BE POSSIBLE EVEN UNDER A
GOOD SITUATION- IN MY OWN
COUNTY THEY ARE TRYING TO DO A
CRIMINAL JURY TRIAL- SENATE
BILL FIVE HUNDRED REQUEST FOR
JUROR. AND GO BACK UP. WHAT TO
SERVE AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME SO
NOT TRUST IN TERMS OF THE
EFFICIENCIES OF THE SYSTEM BUT
AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT AS
WELL- THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE IN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE BY OUR COURTS SO WE
HAVE IT THE NUMBER OF JUDGES
WHO SUPPORT THIS I MENTIONED
TO. IT IS A IT IS SUPPORTED
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION IT HAS THE
SUPPORT OF VIRTUALLY EVERY
PRESIDING JUDGE IN EACH OF THE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA- THIS IS
A MEASURE THAT PROTECTS THE
RIGHTS. OF AN INCH THERE ONCE
THIS HAS BEEN IN PLACE ARE
THERE HAS TO BE A CHALLENGE OR
ANY OBJECTION FILED A TO THE
USE OF SIX PEREMPTORIES AND-
WITH THAT I WOULD REQUEST THAT
WE CONTINUE THAT SUNSET FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS- AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE CURRENT CRISIS. AND
AS WE- TRY TO BE MORE.
EFFICIENT IN THE PROCESS OF
JOBS THIS WHICH THESE JUDGES OF
COURSE ARE THE SINGULAR
INDEPENDENT ARBITER NEED FOR
PROSECUTORS NOR DEFENSE
ATTORNEY THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE. HOME TO AND IN REQUIRED TO
DISPENSE JUSTICE MOST FAIRLY
AND INDEPENDENTLY IT IS THERE A
MEASURE THAT THEY HAD ASKED ME
TO- PRESENT AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
ACTUALLY USE PEREMPTORIES
BEFORE WE TRY TO LIMIT THE USES
ALL OF THEM- RARELY IF EVER DO
WE USE THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT IT IS
STRATEGICALLY VERY BAD THING TO
DO. AND WHEN WE HAVE SIX
PEREMPTORIES WE USUALLY SEE
ARCHER ATTORNEYS USING FOR THE
WHEN WE HIT YOU STEP CAN THEY
NEVER USED THE TENTS SO- THIS
HAS WORKED AND THE JUDGES WOULD
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. THAT
WE CONTINUE WITH THAT SUNSET AN
EXTENDED FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS WITH THAT I WOULD ASK
THREE RIFLE. THANK YOU
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
WINNER. I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE- AND I
DO SO AS SOME OF THE PRACTICE
LAW FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND-
CONDUCTED- FIFTEEN- JURY
TRIALS- THEY WERE NOT CRIMINAL
THEY WERE CIVIL- BUT I'VE- I
PICTURE IS AND I'VE SEEN THE
GOOD AND THE BAD AND THE UGLY
ABOUT HOW JURIES ARE SELECTED.
ON AS A AS A TRIAL ATTORNEY I
ALWAYS LOVED PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES BECAUSE IT GAVE ME A
SENSE THAT I HAD SOME SORT OF
CONTROL HOWEVER I LEARNED OVER
TIME THAT THESE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES ACTUALLY DIDN'T GIVE
ME THAT MUCH CONTROL BECAUSE
PRESS THREE CHALLENGE DURING
HER EARLY BASED ON. STEREOTYPES
PEOPLE. AND I'D BEEN TALK THERE
WERE TIMES WHEN I WOULD STAY
SOMEONE. OF A JURY AND FIND OUT
LATER THAT THEY PROBABLY
WOULDN'T REALLY SYMPATHETIC
RIGHT DIDN'T STRIKE SOMEONE AND
IT TURNED OUT THAT THEY WERE A
NIGHTMARE FOR ME- ON THE JURY-
AND SO WE END UP REALLY USING A
LOT OF STEREOTYPES ON WHEN WE
EXERCISE PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES.
THEY DO HAVE VALUE BECAUSE
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN JUDGES-
MAKE MISTAKES- WHEN A JUDGE
SAID EXCUSE SOMEONE- FOR
BECAUSE AND DOESN'T. AND THAT'S
WHY THEY EXISTS AND SALAS THIS
BILL IS TAKING ON. HI I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL STRIKES
A GOOD. BALANCE BY RETAINING
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES- BUT
ALLOWING THEM TO MASS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE- AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT THEY
ARE NOT AS VALUABLE. AS SOME
PEOPLE SOMETIMES BELIEVE- SO I
ALSO AS FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THAT QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR. WITH ALL TO TAKE
A QUESTION CERTAINLY SO- DAY
THE NOTES THAT I HAVE INDICATE
THAT. THAT THE. THE SPONSORS
MAY BE TAKING AN AMENDMENT OR
SUGGESTING AN AMENDMENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO MAKE IT ONE YEAR SO
I JUST WANTED TO CHECK- WITH
YOU WHETHER THAT'S THE CASE OR
NOT. IF THAT IS THE CASE
SECTION TO ME. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
RESPONSE- THE REASON THAT I AYE
RISES BECAUSE- I DID CRIMINAL
DEFENSE WORK FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND SO I HAD. I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY HUNDREDS OF
JURY TRIALS THAT I PARTICIPATED
IN A PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES. ARE
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU'RE DOING CRIMINAL OFFENSE
WORK- PEOPLE GENERALLY THINK OF
THAT WHEN YOU'RE ACCUSED OF A
CRIME. THAT WHERE THERE'S
SMOKE. THERE'S A FIRE AND SO
WAS PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES
BECOME REALLY IMPORTANT AND-
AND- I WANT TO DISAGREE WITH MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO-
IT MAY BE THAT SOME OTHER
PEOPLE USES USE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES- IN A BIASED WAY.
QUITE FRANKLY I LOOKED AT THE
BODY LANGUAGE I WANTED TO SEE
WHO WASN'T GONNA LOOK ME IN THE
EYE ARE WHO WORKS IN A LOOK AT
MY CLIENT. OR BOB LOOKED
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE READ
WHAT- MY CLIENT WAS CHARGED
WITH AND SO THE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES WERE WERE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT IF IN FACT THIS BILL
IS ON AND I'M AND I'M SO I WAS
PREPARED NOT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL BUT- IF IT'S- REPORT. A
TIME OF A PANDEMIC THEN I AM
ALL FOR THAT AND SO IF IT IF IT
IF THE BILL WOULD BE TO EXTEND
THE SUNSET FOR A YEAR OR MAYBE
TWO YEARS THAT MAKE SENSE TO ME
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS
JUST A- BY THE COURTS TO JUST
NOT HAVE. TO DO. TO HAVE THE
JURY TRIAL. SAYS TAKE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE INCONVENIENT FOR THE FOR
THE JUDGES- AND SO I'M GOING TO
BE LAYING OFF AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME I
THINK IT'S- IT'S A GOOD THING
TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THIS
CORONA VIRUS WE DON'T NEED
PEOPLE COMING IN IF WE PAY FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR- DESPERATELY
LOOKING FOR JURORS BUT I'M JUST
IT. THREE YEARS TO ME SEEMS-
EXCESSIVE IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION SO I RESPECT THE-
WILL NOT BE VOTING. DO YOU.
KNOW DISCUSSION ORDERED. ON
THIS ITEM SEEING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES CENTER JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IS
THANK YOU I HAVE TAKEN THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
NUMBER OF PRESIDING JUDGES
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTED IN OF SPENT A LIFE
COMMITTED TO THE ADMINISTRATION
OF JUSTICE FAIRLY IMPARTIALLY
AND WITHOUT FAVOR TO EITHER
SIDE. OUR SHOWS A CROSS OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS HAS PROVED
EFFECTIVE PRODUCTIVE IN TERMS
OF ALLOWING PEOPLE TO HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT. IT IS A
PROCESS BILL I THINK A IF AND
IF ALLOWED TO CONTINUE WILL
DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE ARE
ACTUALLY ONLY TWO STATES IN THE
COUNTRY. THAT ALLOW FOR MORE
PEREMPTORY PUNCHES THEN WHAT WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA THERE
IS EXCUSE FOR CALLS AND THERE
ARE CIRCUMSTANCES AS MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
POINTED OUT. WE WERE PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO LOOK TO OR YOUR
CLIENT UPSIDE DOWN AND INSIDE
OUT AND YOU GET TO USE THEM FOR
COST. TO RENT TO REACH YOU GET
TO EXCLUSION FOR ANY YOU. OUR
WHICH MEANS THAT YOU TO BE IF
YOU IF YOU HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER YOU'VE GOT TO BE REALLY
CLEAR. AND AS MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO SAID
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE ROLLING DICE. THEN USING
A PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE YOU
THINK SOMEONE ISN'T GOING TO BE
A GOOD. JUROR FOR YOU TURNS OUT
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN A GREAT
TEACHER. BUT LIMITING THIS TO
SIX I IS SOMETHING THAT AS I
MENTIONED I COULD TO LIST OFF
ALL THE- OPERAS IN JUDGING. ARE
IN BEFORE YOU PURCHASE ALL OF
THEM SUPPORT THIS MEASURE I
TRUST IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE. BUT
IN TERMS OF THE QUALITY OF
JUSTICE AND AS I MENTIONED WE
HAVE YET TO SEE SINGLE. DEFENSE
FOR A STATE. AND A P. ON THIS
ISSUE. HAS BEEN WORKING IT
CONTINUES TO WORK. ROGER BUT IT
OVER WELL PLEASE ENTER THAT ARE
RESPECT. REQUEST Q. MENEM'S
PLEASE THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS I BATES
I FELL. FORGES I BRADFORD. CUT
BY ADAM. CHIANG I DALLY I DON.
I ASSUME I GALGIANI. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. GROWTH HERTZBERG I
HILL I HUESO. I TADO. I JACKSON
I JONES I LEYVA. MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ. MITCHELL MONNING. I
MORE LOCK I RURAL. NIELSEN I
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN. I I'M
BURKE I WHY CASTING. I WIENER I
WILK HI. MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
BELL. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
GALGIANI GONZALEZ. GROWTH I.
LEYVA MELENDEZ. MITCHELL
MORRELL. RUBIO SKINNER. HI IS
TWENTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN SENATOR
GLAZER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT I DON'T IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TEN
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACTUAL LATE RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. USER THANK YOU ARE
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS
PAST HALLOWEEN. A SHORT TERM
RENTAL PROPERTY WAS RESERVE BY
A WHAT WAS ALLEGED TO BE TWO
FAMILIES COMING TOGETHER FOR A
REUNION- IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND SAID SOMETHING QUITE
DIFFERENT HAPPENED A- OR TIES
THAT WENT OUT ON THE INTERNET.
FOR A PARTY. AND A GIANT PARTY
DID TAKE PLACE HI THIS
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD. THE
POLICE WERE CALLED. BUT BEFORE
THEY COULD ARRIVE. A GUN FIGHT
BROKE OUT. AND FIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE WERE KILLED. AND FOR
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WERE
SERIOUSLY INJURED. THIS HOUSE
WITH A SHORT TERM RENTAL TOOK
PLACE WAS NOT A- DO. PLACER
PROBLEM TO THE LOCAL POLICE
THEY'VE BEEN AWARE OF ABUSES
THAT IT HAPPENED AT THIS
PROPERTY. BUT UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW TODAY. THE PENALTY FOR
SOMEONE WHO USES A SHORT TERM
RENTAL IN VIOLATION OF CITY OR
COUNTY RULES COULD BE AS
EXPENSIVE AS A HUNDRED DOLLAR
FINE. THIS LEGISLATION ATTEMPTS
TO PROVIDE SOME TOOLS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. WHERE IN THOSE GET
A CASES AND AN ABUSE HAPPENED
WITH SHORT TERM RENTALS. IT
ALLOWS FOR A FINE OF A LITTLE
BT MORE MEETING YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU READ THESE PROPERTIES
CERTAINLY LARGER HOMES YOU CAN
RENT THEM FOR ONE TO THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A NIGHT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED TO HAVE SOME
TOOL TO HOLD THOSE OWNERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ABUSE THAT'S
WHAT THIS LEGISLATION ATTEMPTS
TO DO. WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT OF. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEN IN HEARING NINE
MOUNT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA OR AYE
ATKINS I BATES. I FELL I FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I CHIANG.
DALLY I DON. I ASSUME I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HILL I
HUESO. I TADO I JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING I MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN I PAN I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN I AM BURKE I KNOW I WHITE
HOUSE SKI. I WIENER I WILK NO.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST NO
CHIANG NO GROWTH. HI IS THIRTY
TWO NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PSSES
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT CENTER I'M BURKE
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL NINE
NINETY NINE BY SENATOR UMBERG
AN ACT RELATING TO MOBILE
HOMES. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB NINE
NINE NINE A BILL THAT WOULD
RESTORE LOCAL RENT
STABILIZATION ORDINANCES- TO
THOSE WHO LIVE IN MOBILE HOME
PARKS THIS DOES NOT CREATE RENT
CONTROL THIS DOES NOT CREATE
RENT STABILIZATION IT'S SIMPLY.
CREATES A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR THOSE LIVE IN MOBILE HOME
PARKS AS ALL OF YOU KNOW MOBILE
HOMES AND MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE
NOT LIKE TRADITIONAL HOUSING IN
THE SENSE THAT IF YOU LIVE IN
APARTMENT YOU RENT GOES UP YOU
COULD MOVE. IF YOU LIVE IN A
HOUSE YOU OWN THE HOUSE DOESN'T
MATTER. WHAT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS THIS BILL SAYS THAT. IF
YOU LIVE IN A MOBILE HOME PARK.
IN YOU HAVE A LONG TERM LEASE
CURRENT LAW SAYS THAT YOU
CANNOT AVAIL YOURSELF OF THE
PROTECTIONS OF LOCAL RENT
CONTROL. THIS BILL DOES IS SAYS
IF YOU SIGN A LONG TERM LEASE
AFTER FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR.
YOU CAN'T AVAIL YOURSELF. OF
THE PROTECTIONS OF LOCAL RENT
CONTROL RENT STABILIZATION.
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. ON
THE LAW THIS BILL PROVIDES
THAT. LONG TERM LEASES NO
LONGER PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION
FROM LOCAL RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCES. OF THOSE THAT LIVE
IN MOBILE HOME PARKS. ARE
SOMETIMES IT QUITE OFTEN FACT.
SO ARE MOST VULNERABLE AND
PARTICULARLY SENIORS ON FIXED
INCOMES TONIGHT VOTE. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING SEEN NINE
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FACE NO BELL I FORGES
NO BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG
NO DALLY NO DODD. THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI. GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HILL I
HUESO AYE AYE TADO I JACKSON I
JONES. NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL I MONNING
I MORE LOCK NO MORRELL. NO
NIELSEN NO PAN. I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER RIGHT I WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER I WILK. NO.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. AB FERN. DODD I
GALGIANI. GLAZER HERTZBERG.
PRICE TWENTY FIVE MILLS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL NOW
MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
NINE. WE HAVE CENTER JACKSON
AGAIN SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWELVE AU SEVEN BY SNATOR
JACKSON AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH FACILITIES SENATE
JACKSON THANK YOU MISTRESS AND
COLLEAGUES ARE AS PART OF THE
WILDFIRE TASK FORCE WE WERE
ATTACHED TO LOOK- TO SEE HOW
OUR MOST VULNERABLE. WERE
HANDLING THE PS PS SITUATION
AND OUR WILDFIRES AND WHAT WE
DISCOVERED IS THAT EVEN THOUGH
MOST OF THESE FACILITIES ARE
FEDERALLY- LICENSED WITH THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY HAVE
NINETY SIX HOURS OF BACK UP
ELECTRICITY SO THAT THEY CAN
CARE FOR. THEIR VULNERABLE-
POPULATION- THERE IS STILL A
PERCENTAGE. OF CALIFORNIA
LICENSE COMPANIES THAT DO NOT
PROVIDE THAT NINETY SIX HOURS
IN FACT THEY ONLY PROVIDE SIX
HOURS. NOW EVEN IN THOSE
FACILITIES THAT ARE FEDERALLY
LICENSED THERE IS A QUESTION.
OF AMONGST THOSE FEDERAL-
FACILITIES THE- FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. HAS ALREADY- FOR
INDICATED THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IT IS TO
OVERSEE THEM. I INDICATED IN A
REPORT A COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT
EVEN ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL THESE
REQUIREMENTS WERE NOT BEING MET
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT REQUIRES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO APPLY AND TO
INCORPORATE THAT FEDERAL
MANDATE INTO STATE LAW AND OUR
HOPE IS OF COURSE THAT WILL
START SEEING THIS BETTER
IMPLEMENTED WHEN YOU THINK OF
THE WHEN WE HAVE A P. S. P. S.
AND WE'VE BEEN TOLD BY P.
JEANNIE IN PARTICULAR. TO
EXPECT MANY MORE OF THEM WHEN
WE THINK OF THE SITUATION IN
THE IN THE COVERT REALITY IN
WHICH WE LIVE AND THE FACT THAT
IT'S DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY EVAC BUT
THESE PEOPLE ARE WHEN THERE IS
A FIRE OR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THEIR MEDICATIONS
PROTECTED. OXYGEN AVAILABLE TO
THEM THE OTHER THINGS THAT
THESE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
PEOPLE ARE REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
SURVIVE THAT'S ALL THIS BILL
DOES IT REALLY- JUST EXPANDS
THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO NINETY
SIX HOURS- SO THAT THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THE THROES OF THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH OUR
CURRENT PANDEMIC. BUT ALSO WHO
IN MANY INSTANCES WHETHER IT'S
WILDFIRES TO WE THEY ARE
PROJECTED FOR THESE P. S. P. S.
IS. NOT HEARD TELL OF THE
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY NEED
TRUST TO BE ABLE TO SERVE FIVE
WITHIN SOCIAL. HAVING AVAILABLE
TO THEM THAT IMPORTANT
ELECTRICITY TO HELP KEEP THEM
ALIVE AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THE FOR THE STATION
SENATOR OF. AN MR FOR. I RISE
IN OF THE BILL I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT TIME WE
REALIZE THAT EVEN WITH COATED
AND THE P. S. P. S. SITUATIONS
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY
ESPECIALLY WITH THE KOBE
SITUATION HAVE BEEN. THE MOST
ELDERLY AND WAS FRAIL
INDIVIDUALS IN SOCIETY THAT ARE
SEE IN THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ESPECIALLY HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THESE
FACILITIES ARE REGULATED AND
LICENSED BY THE STATE I KNOW IN
MY COUNTY AND KERN COUNTY OVER
55% OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
LOST THEIR LIVES BECAUSE A KOBE
CAME FROM ONE FACILITY ONE
PARTICULAR FACILITY. SO IT IS
VERY DISTURBING TO THINK THAT
ARE MOST ELDERLY AND MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
OR NOT BEING CARED FOR IN THE
WAY THAT THEY SHOULD I THINK
THE SENATORS BILL WILL- AT IT
AS A PROTECTION SO THAT WHEN WE
DO HAVE A P. S. P. S. SITUATION
AND THEY DO HAVE BACKUP
GENERATORS TO MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ON OXYGEN
AND OTHER. FORMS OF LIFE
SUSTAINING AND MEDICATIONS AND
STUFF THAT THEY WOULD FIRST. I
GUESS APPARATUSES THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
SECURE AT LEAST UNTIL POWER IS
RESTORED BUT I'D ALSO LIKE YOU
GUYS MY COLLEAGUES THINK ABOUT
THE A STRAIN ON SOME OF THESE
FACILITIES YOU KNOW WE'VE PASS
MANDATES OVER THE YEARS FOR
INCREASED A MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE COSTS BUT YET MEDICARE
RATES A REIMBURSEMENT RATES
HAVE GONE DOWN. SOME OF US WHEN
WE HAVE OUR APPEARANCE OR
INDIVIDUALS INSIDE OF SOME OF
THESE CARE FACILITIES THEIR
PRIVATE FACILITIES WHERE YOU
PAY ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FIRST
FOR CARE AND QUALITY CARE I
KNOW THAT MY MOM DIED OF
DEMENTIA WE HAD- IN A FACILITY
FOR THE LAST THIRTY DAYS OR SO
OVER LIFE. SHE LIVES I SAID
PRIOR TO THAT IT SUBSTANTIAL
EVERY MONTH THE PAYMENT BUT SHE
GOT GOOD CARE BUT SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS MOST OF THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE FACILITIES
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
THERE ARE REGULATED BY THE
STATE. ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
MEDICAID OR MEDICARE AND
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS VERY VERY
LOW SOMEONE INCREASE EVERY
PASSED THIS BUILDING THAT
INCREASE THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS THE NOT AFFECTS DIRECT
PATIENT CARE THIS IS ISN'T IT.
COST MANDATE WOULD BE HIS FIRST.
FOR CHEN BACK. AGAIN IS THE-
RATE FOR THE MEDIC READ. WHICH
IS EXTREMELY LOW SO WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT. BUT I DO HOLY
SUPPORT THE BILL TO ALLOW AND A
GENERATOR TO BE PLACED IN THOSE
FACILITIES. SO WHEN WE ARE
ABSENT WITHOUT POWER THAT THESE
PEOPLE COULD BE TAKING CARE OF
AS THEY ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY. RIGHT
CENTER MELENDEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT- SO I AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS RELATING TO
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FOLKS IN THESE FACILITIES
ARE CARED FOR IN AN
APPROPRIATELY MY CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL IS THAT IT DOESN'T
APPEAR TO PROVIDE THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY- AS THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS DO AND I JUST
WONDER IF YOU COULD COMMENT. ON
THE INHERENT DANGER THAT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH STORING THAT
MUCH FUEL ON SITE FOR NINETY
SIX HOURS OF POWER SHOULD THEY
NEED TO DO THAT THAT'S I MEAN
THAT'S A LOT OF FUEL SO. IF YOU
WANT TO DRESS CITING YOUR
CLOTHES OR NOW WHATEVER IS
FINE- MISTER PRESIDENT BUT
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT I HAVE-
AND I WOULD. LOVE SOME CLARITY
ON THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR GLAZER. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF HAPPY TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION SENATOR DODD AND I
HAVE- SO HAVING BACKUP
GENERATORS IS ONLY ONE PART OF
THE SOLUTION NOW. A CENTER DOT
AND I HAVE A BILL THAT DEALS
WITH OTHER CRITICAL FACILITIES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES HOSPITAL'S
WATER PLANTS. THAT HAVE BACKUP
GENERATORS BUT BECAUSE OF- AIR
REGULATIONS. PUT RISK
POTENTIALLY PUT RESTRICTIONS ON
THEIR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY RUN
THE- ANSWER BY- GUIDANCE TO THE
AUTHOR- IS TO AS IS. TO THE
ASSEMBLY IS THAT CONSIDERED AN
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENT TO HER
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT HAVING
THE GENERATOR IS ONE THING BUT
MAKE SURE THAT YOU BILL RUN.
AND THAT THERE IS A HUGE. AND
BURDEN PLACED ON THESE THIS BOB
REGARDING YOUR QUALITY DON'T
DOESN'T GET IN THE WAY OF THE
GOOD GOALS THE CHEESE OUTLINED
IN THE BILL AND WHY I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN. FAMOUS PRESIDENT
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE AND BEEN THROUGH TOO
MANY OF THESE INCIDENTS- HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER LIVING IN ONE OF
THESE SNIFFS AND IT'S AN
EXPERIENCE TO GO THROUGH EVEN
IF THEY'RE AT A WELL FACILITY
LET ALONE. FACILITY THAT
DOESN'T LOOK AFTER THEIR
THERE'S- I WOULD I WOULD RAISE
I WOULD CLARIFY THE BILL
DOESN'T SPECIFY- THE EXACT
SOURCE OF WHERE THE BACKUP
POWER COMES FROM IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY DEFAULT- TO DIESEL
GENERATION THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT KIND OF- HERE DISTRICT
OVERSIGHT OR THE- BACKUP FUEL
CAPACITY I THINK THAT WAS MEANT.
IN SOME OPPOSITE THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE THREE PEOPLE
ON SITE OF WE HAVE AN
EXTREMELY- ENCOURAGING
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE
FOR THESE KINDS OF FACILITIES
TO INSTALL A FUEL CELL BATTERY
STORAGE SYSTEM ON SITE. COMBINE
THAT WITH THE TURBINE. LOOK AT
THEIR RIGHT WIENER SOLUTIONS I
THEY CAN ALSO MEET THIS TEST
THAT MADE MAY BE ABLE TO OFFSET
ANY OF THOSE ISSUES WITH YEAR
DISTRICTS AND COULD FIND A MORE
EXPEDITIOUS PAT FORDE SO LOOK
FOR TO STAYING GAUGE ON THE
ISSUE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FOR. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL. GREATER DISCUSSION
ON THE SIDE ON SCENE NO
ADDITIONAL MIKE'S THROUGH
JACKSON TALK TO CLOSETHANK YOU
SO MUCH YES AND I APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION THIS IS A BILL
STILL IN PROGRESS THIS IS A-
VERY. SORT OF. ONE A LOGICAL
BUILD WANT TO PROTECT OUR
SENIORS ARE MOST VULNERABLE IN
THESE OF THE SENIOR NURSING
FACILITIES- TO RESPOND TO MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS AVAILABLE AND
INCENTIVES HOPEFULLY TO BE
AVAILABLE- AS FAR AS THE KIND
OF BACK UP GENERATION I KNOW
THAT THE SOLAR INDUSTRY
SUPPORTS THIS BILL I BELIEVE
THEY THINK THAT THEY CAN. BE OF
ASSISTANCE REDUCING POTENTIAL
FOR HEAVY FUELS ON A FACILITY-
TO GENERATE THE NINETY SIX
HOURS WORTH OF ELECTRICITY- I
AM NOT AWARE THAT THIS BILL
WILL AFFECT A QUOTE UNQUOTE
FLEXIBILITY MY UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT ON THE- LEVEL. IS AT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S BOARD
INDICATES CONCERN THAT OF THE
FEDERALLY LICENSED FACILITIES
ARE NOT EVEN MEET. US FEDERAL
STANDARDS ARE THEY ARE IN
PLACE- SO AT AND I AM MORE THAN
TO KEEP ME WORKING ON HOW WE
GOING TO MAKE. UP FOR THESE FOR
BUT WE KNOW WE AND. THE THERE
WERE A LOT OF. AND WILL CAN TO
BE ON THE BEST WAY TO DO THE
BUT BASS THE SIMPLY A- THE
NINETY SIX HOUR REQUIREMENT TO
ALL OF OUR STATE FACILITIES
WITH THE HOPES THAT WE WILL.
MAKE SURE THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE SENIORS ARE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND ARE SAFE
DURING THESE CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES- THAT HAVE BEEN
AGAIN MADE EVEN MORE
COMPLICATED BY OUR TO SITUATE
SO WITH THAT ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIFLE. THANKS MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE BATES ATKINS AYE
BATES. WELL I FOR JUST I
BRADFORD FIVE COME BY ADAM I
CHIANG I DALLY. I DODD I
THEY'RE AWESOME I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. MITCHELL
FIVE MONNING I MORE LOCK EURO.
I NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT I
WHITE HOUSE SKI BY WIENER. I
WILK HI. MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
I JONES. MELENDEZ MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN. I JUST THIRTY SIX NOTE
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY.
CENTER STERN- YOU PREFER HE IS
NOT OKAY FAIR YOU PREPARE FOR
THAT MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
THREE. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BY TE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
RESOURCES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR. STERN
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS IS THE SENATE
AFTER RESOURCE IN WATERS I
COMMITTEE CLEANUP BILL
CONTAINING TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
AND NON CONTROVERSIAL STATUTORY
CHANGES. IN THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE GRAMMATICAL
TWEAKS AND THE COASTAL ACT AS
AS WELL AS CLARIFYING CHANGES-
CONCERNING THE RETENTION AND
SALES SCHOOL LANDS AN INDEMNITY
LANCE THE BILL AS UNANIMOUS IN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. YES FOR
RIVAL. QUESTION ON THIS ITEM.
MEMBERS THIS IS ALL THE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION AND USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. SENIOR NINE EYES FORTY NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE.
SOONER MINING ARE YOU PREPARED
HE IS MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
OH TWO BY SENATOR MINING AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT THURMOND.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS MEMBERS LAST YEAR MORE
THAN TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
FOREIGN FARMWORKERS WERE
IMPORTED BY ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA GROWERS IN FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS UNDER THE H.
TWO A FEDERAL V. SO PROGRAM.
THIS NUMBER HAS BEEN INCREASING
ANNUALLY FOR THOSE OF YOU
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE H. TO A
PROGRAM IT HAS MANY OF THE SAME
PROVISIONS AND PROBLEMS THAT
THE INFAMOUS FOR SERRA PROGRAM
HAD WHICH WAS TERMINATED
BECAUSE OF SYSTEMIC LABOR
HOUSING IN WAGE ABUSES. THE H.
TO A FARM WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE LARGELY RECRUITED IN MEXICO
ARE TIED TO A SINGLE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER WHO MUST PROVIDE THEM
WITH HOUSING. MEALS AND
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK SITES.
MANY AGE TO A WORKERS HAVE
NEVER BEEN TO CALIFORNIA BEFORE
AND ARE BELIEVED TO NEITHER
SPEAK NOR READ ENGLISH. IF THEY
ARE FIRED FOR ANY REASON
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO IMMEDIATE
DEPORTATION WHICH IS A POWERFUL
DISINCENTIVE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
ANY ABUSE OF WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS. THEY MAY BE
SUBJECTED TO. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN OH TWO REQUIRES H. TO
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE EACH TO A
FARMWORKERS ON THEIR FIRST DAY
AT WORK WITH A SHORT
COMPREHENSIVE WRITTEN SUMMARY
OF KEY LABOR HOUSING HEALTH AND
SAFETY. REGULATIONS IN
PROTECTIONS IN OTHER CALIFORNIA
LAWS IN SPANISH AND IF
REQUESTED IN ENGLISH. ONE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT FEATURES OF
THIS BILL MEMBERS IS DURING THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS. WE'VE
SEEN ONE OF THE HIGHEST SPIKES.
IN COVERT NINETEEN INFECTIONS
AMONG IMMIGRANT FARM WORKERS.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES NOTICE
TO INCLUDE THE DECLARATION OF
ANY EMERGENCY THAT COULD TO
SURROUND. THE WORKPLACE WHERE
THE WORKER IS BEING. TAKEN TO
FOR WORK- THE COVERT NINETEEN
VIRUS IS INDEED INTERNATIONAL
PART OF A PANDEMIC. BUT FOR
WORKERS IN AGRICULTURE THE
RISKS HAVE BEEN REPORTED AS
EVEN GREATER BECAUSE OF THE
CLOSE PROXIMITY AND HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND WORKPLACE.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN- TO CREATE A
SAFER LEGALLY COMPLIANT
WORKPLACE FOR H. TO A
FARMWORKERS AND REDUCES ANY
INCENTIVES THAT UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS MIGHT HAVE TO HIRE
WORKERS WHOM THEY CAN UNDER
PAYING MISTREAT BECAUSE THE
WORKERS DO NOT UNDERSTAND THEIR
RIGHTS OR HOW TO HAVE THEM IN
FORCED. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NINE MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE WORLD. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BELL I FOR JUST NO BRADFORD
I HAVE A YELLOW. CHIANG NO
DALLY NO DODD. THERE ARE SO. I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HELLO I
HUESO. I TADO. JACKSON I JONES.
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
HAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN I AM BURKE
I WHAT CASKEY I WIENER. I WILK.
HOME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I
CABALLERO. DODD GLAZER. GROWTH
NO TADO. RUBIO I SKINNER I WILK
NO. AUGUST TWENTY FIVE NO
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW MEMBERS TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE. CENTER MORE
LOCKER YOU PREPARED HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
BY SENATOR MORE LOCKED AN ACT
RELATING TO NON VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION. FIGURE MORLOCK THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT- JUST
CURIOUS IF I COULD START WITH A
PERSONAL POINT OF PRIVILEGE.
JUST WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT MISTER CHAIR
MISTER PRESIDENT. THE SPEAKING
TO THE BILL A REPORT ON YOUR
PERSONAL POINT OF PRIVILEGE
JUST WANNA ANNOUNCED MY NEWEST
GRANDCHILD I APOLOGIZE- ALL.
RIGHT GRANT. GET THE MOTHER IS
A WRECK A FORMER RESIDENT OF
GUARDINO MISTER PRESIDENT AT
ONE OF YOUR CONSTITUENCY IS.
AND SO COLLEAGUES JUST WANTED
TO ANNOUNCE THAT- BOOK IN. CODE
ZERO YOUR HIGHNESS MORE LIKE
WAS BORN ON THE SEVENTEENTH AT
EIGHT FORTY ONE AM IS NINE AND
NINE POUNDS ONE OUNCE TWENTY
ONE INCHES PUTS A LOT LIKE HIS
FATHER WHEN HE WAS A NEWBORN.
AND THE U. ELEVEN MONICA. IT IS
THEIR SECOND IT IS OUR FIFTH
AND WE'RE EXPECTING NUMBER SIX
IN DECEMBER WITH MY DAUGHTER SO
TO. PRODUCTIVE YEARS OLD THIS
ONE TO ANNOUNCE THAT THANK YOU.
NO TO THE BILL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT IT WAS THIS IT WAS A
CASUAL CONVERSATION ONE A DAY
WITH THE MAYOR OF. OF MY CITY
HE HAD RECENTLY REMODELED HIS
ENTIRE HOME IT'S A GORGEOUS-
MISSION STYLE FORMAT. ANY
MENTION YOU KNOW WHEN I
REMODELED I WENT AHEAD AND PUT
IN A GENERATOR. AND I HAVE A-
POWERED BY NATURAL GAS AND
EDISON HAD A POWER OUTAGE
RECENTLY AND- IT WAS OUT FOR A
GOOD EIGHT HOURS BUT HIS HOME
WAS THE ONLY ONE LIT UP ON THE
STREET FOR THAT ENTIRE PERIOD
OF TIME AND IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
ALL MY GOODNESS NATURAL GAS. OF
COURSE WHY ARE WE USING THAT
WOULD WE HAVE BACKUP GENERATORS
SO WHERE NATURAL GAS IS
AVAILABLE AND PROPANE IS
AVAILABLE IT SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED FOR BACKUP
GENERATORS. THE THOUGHT OF
TRANSPORTING DIESEL WHICH WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED EARLIER
ESPECIALLY DURING A FIRE
CONFLAGRATION IS FRIGHTENING
LET ALONE THE STORAGE OF AN ON
SITE BUT CLEANER FUELS LIKE
NATURAL GAS AND PROPANE SHOULD
STRONGLY BE. WHEN EMERGENCY
INSIST TO A BACKUP GENERATOR IT
FOR. LIKE IN ONE OR MORE OF THE
RECENT PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF THE ARE NOW CALLED PS PS.
AND EXCEED THE MAXIMUM ANNUAL A
LOT OF TIME FOR THE YEAR. CLEAN
BURNING GENERATORS EXEMPTED TO
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE UPDATES
THE FOR THESE NATURAL GAS
PROPANE GENERATORS. IS NOT
DURING THE EXISTING DIESEL
GENERATORS BE REPLACED. AND
LANGUAGE WILL BE A- INSERTED.
TO CLARIFY THIS INCORRECT
ASSUMPTION- WHEN WE TAKE IT
OVER HOPEFULLY TO THE ASSEMBLY
BUT LET'S CLARIFY THE CODE FOR
THE FOR THOSE WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT GENERATING ENERGY WHEN
NEEDED AND DO IT WITH FUELS
THAT ARE BETTER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN ON SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
STERN THANK YOU MISS PRESENT
QUESTION THE AUTHOR. LOT THAT
THE QUESTION PLEASE THANK YOU A
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AT AT I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BEEN. NOT JUST IN A
PERSONA CAPACITY BUT
PROFESSIONALLY ALSO WORKING ON
THIS- HERITAGE ISSUE IN FIRE
ZONES FOR A WHILE. WE KNOW THAT
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION IS
CONCERNED THAT- NATURAL GAS IS
REALLY THE ONLY TECHNOLOGY
REALLY CALLED OUT AS A CLEAN IN
FEASIBLE ALTERNATIVE. AND I'M
WONDERING- THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL SEEMS TO ALSO ACCOMMODATE
EITHER- CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES
SOLAR STORAGE OF FUEL CELLS- ISTHERE AN INTENT- WITH WITH THIS
BILL TO ALSO. PUSH FOR THOSE
OTHER CLEAN ALTERNATE IS AS
OPPOSED TO JUST A NATURAL GAS
ALTERNATIVE TO DIESEL WE WERE
WE'RE HOPING THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION FOR THE- PRESIDENT- WE
WERE HOPING TO ALSO ADD
PROPANE- WIN WOMEN THE BILL IN
THE ASSEMBLY. BUT I'M HAPPY TO
MAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS AS WELL.
IT THANK YOU AT YET IT'S HARD
TO. STAND UP AND PUSH FOR JUST
TO FOSSIL FUEL VERSUS FOSSIL
FUEL APPROACH I THINK I CAN
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THOUGH IF I
DO HAVE SOME CLARITY THAT
RENEWABLE SOURCES OF POWER ARE
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT AS IT
CURRENTLY COST EFFECTIVE
FEASIBLE ALTERNATIVE TO BOTH
GAS AND DIESEL SO. IF THERE'S
SOME WAY TO JUST NOT PUT TOO
HEAVY OF A THUMB ON THESCALE I
THINK THAT WOULD GO A LONG
WAYS. THANK YOU. SOONER
ARTILLERY YES QUESTION FOR THE
OFFICE. BUT AS ONE OF THE
CLARIFIED. SEPT PLEASE AS WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT USING ALSO THE
ALL SYSTEMS ALL OPPORTUNITIES
THERE EVERY EVERY YEAR BIT OF
ENERGY THAT YOU COULD FIND
OTHER THAN JUST NAME MEANS GAS
AND WE HEARD ABOUT DIESEL WE
HEARD. ABOUT OTHERS AND THERE'S
A HYDROGEN IN THE FUTURE
BATTERIES IN THE FUTURE YEARS
TO COME WHO KNOWS. I MEAN
YOU'RE OPEN TO THAT THAT'S MY
QUESTION. I THINK WE'RE OPEN TO
THAT I WHERE WE REALIZE IS THAT
WE HAD- AN ENERGY SOURCE. THAT
WAS NOT ALLOWED FOR IN THE CODE
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WAS. TAKEN CARE OF BUT I'M
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS- THE PROBLEMI
HAD WHEN I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR OF THE CODE WAS
SILENT YOU COULDN'T DO IT SO-
OUR REACTION WAS ALL MY
GOODNESS LET'S LET'S PROVIDE
FOR- THIS ABILITY- ESPECIALLY
IF YOU'RE READY OF BUSINESS FOR
A HOSPITAL THAT HAS ACCESS TO.
THE NATURAL GAS KNACK FOR YOU
KNOW ON. A IS A FORMER BUSINESS
SO WHY NOT HAVE A GENERATOR
THAT'S POWER. THAT WAY AND
PROVIDE FOR EMERGENCY
VARIANCES. SO WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO ACCOMMODATE SOMETHING THAT
MAKES A WHOLE LOT OF SENSE AND
pIS A WHOLE LOT. CLEANER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT THAN DIESEL. THANK
YOU FOR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SHEENA AND SENATOR MORE LIKE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I APPRECIATE THE
INPUT. THANK YOU. RENTS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES I TELL I GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO I CHIANG
I DOLLY. DODD I THERE ARE SO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ.
GROVE HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO.
I TADO I JACKSON. JONES I LEYVA
NO MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S I
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK
I MORAL. I NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I AM STERN. NUMBER
NINE I LIKE CASTING. I WIENER.
NO WILK. I MMHM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JULY MITCHELL I DON'T KNOW. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OF AB TO
MEMBERS. VALLEY. GONZALEZ
GROWTH I JACKSON. STERN. THREE
THREE. ALL RIGHTS THIRTY THREE
KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR SENATOR GALGIANI
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
GALGIANI AN ACT RELATING TO
ANIMALS. ENTER GALGIANI FLOORS
OR SHOULD CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
DATA FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CALIFORNIA
EUTHANIZED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CATS AND
DOGS STATEWIDE IN A SINGLE YEAR
THIS BILL WILL CHANGE
LIMITATIONS AND CURRENT LAW
THAT PREVENT ANIMAL SHELTERS
FROM GIVING PROPER TREATMENT.
PET OWNERS CAN GIVE THEIR
ANIMALS OVER THE COUNTER
MEDICATIONS BUT STATE LAW
CURRENTLY PROHIBITS NON
VETERINARY MEDICAL SHELTER
STAFF FROM BEING ABLE TO DO THE
SAME THIS MEANS THAT IF AN
ANIMAL COMES INTO A SHELTER THE
STAFF CAN EUTHANIZING ANIMALS
CANNOT TREAT FOR FLEAS. THIS
BILL WILL EQUALIZE THE ABILITY
FOR ANIMAL SHELTER CARE TAKERS
TO PROVIDE FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF AN ANIMAL AND THE
SAME DAY THE WHEN I CAN CARE
FOR OUR OUR OWN PETS UNDER
CURRENT LAW I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. ANY DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
CHAIN NINE MONTHS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES.
BELL FIVE GORGEOUS I BRADFORD I
CUT BY ADAM I CHIANG I DOLLY. I
DON. I THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI
I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON I JONES. FIVE
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S
AYE MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE
LOCK. MORRELL I NIELSEN I CAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN I NUMBER RIGHT
I LIKE HOUSE HE- I WIENER I
WILK HI MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. EIGHT
I MORE LOCK HI. NICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
SIX. BY SENATOR MINING.
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
THREE SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR MINING
AND ACTUALLY BEING TO
EMPLOYMENT. MONEY THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS UNDER
EXISTING LAW WHEN AN EMPLOYEE
FILES A WAGE CLAIM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER PLACE IN A JEW TO
CONTORT YOUR ROLE IN THE
HEARING IF THE HEARING RESULTS
IN AN ORDER DECISION OR AWARD
IN FAVOR THE CLAIMANT AND THE
EMPLOYER FILES SO DID NOVO
APPEAL OF THAT- DA AND THE
CLAIMANT CANNOT AFFORD PRIVATE
COUNSEL. THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
IS REQUIRED TO REPRESENT THE
CLAIMANT IN THE DID NOVO
PROCEEDINGS HOWEVER WHEN A WAGE
CLAIM IS FORCED TO ARBITRATE
WHICH CLAIM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S UNABLE TO
PROVIDE NO COST REPRESENTATION.
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
UPDATE EXISTING LAW AND ALLOW
CLAIMANTS AN ARBITRATION
PROCEEDINGS TO RECEIVE NO COST
REPRESENTATION FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE INCREASED USE OF
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS BY
AUTHORIZING THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO REPRESENT WAGE
CLAIMANTS AN ARBITRAL
PROCEEDINGS WHEN THEY ARE
UNABLE TO RESOLVE THE WAGE
CLAIM DURING THE DURING.
MEMBERS THERE'S NO ISSUE ON
FILE IT'S ACTUALLY. A REFORM
THAT THINK INNER TO THE BENEFIT
OF BOTH. AN EMPLOYEE WITH THE
CLAIM AND AN EMPLOYER WHO MAIN
DISPUTE THAT CLAIM. PROVIDING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE THE
CASE OUTSIDE OF COURT.
CURRENTLY WITH COURTS BEING
BACKED UP UNDER COVERT NINETEEN
THIS REFORM IS ACTUALLY I THINK
IN THE INTEREST OF ALL PARTIES
TO SUCH A DISPUTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF THE RATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEN NINE MEDICAL
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE. BELL I FORGES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A ADAM I CHIANG I DOLLY.
DODD I THEY'RE AWESOME. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG I HILL I WITH
SO. I TADO. I JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE
LOCK MORRELL. NO NIELSEN NO HAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER. I STERN I AM VERY I
LIKE HOW TO SKI. I WIENER I
WILK I MMHM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS DATE. FOR
JUST. DALLY NO. GROWTH NO MORE
LOCK NO. VICE THIRTY ONE NO
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE SENATOR SKINNER YOU
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY
TWO BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION. SENATOR
SKINNER. OKAY THERE YOU GO.
THEY WILL START AGAIN. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDING OFFICER
MEMBERS SO WE POLICYMAKERS AND
OF COURSE THE PUBLIC WOULD BE
MUCH BETTER POSITIONED TO
DISCUSS EVALUATE AND MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT. HE
TERRY POLICY IF WE HAD ACCESS
TO SPECIFIC DATA ON THE MANY
TAX CREDITS WE PROVIDE. WHO
TAKES THEM WHAT BENEFITS ARE
THEY PROVIDING CAN IN RECENT
YEARS AS WE HAVE ADOPTED TAX
CREDITS LIKE THE FILM TAX
CREDIT WE HAVE REQUIRED THAT
THOSE ENTITIES THAT TAKE US
TAKE IT INFORM US THAT THEY ARE
TAKING THAT TAX CREDIT. AND
GIVE US THE INFORMATION AS TO
THE- JOBS THEY CREATED FILMS
THEY PRODUCED IT CETERA IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW SB NINE SEVENTY
TWO DOES NOT GO THAT FAR WHY
WOULD. WHAT THE BILL TO
BASICALLY GIVE US INFORMATION
ON EVERY SINGLE TAX CREDIT. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE COST FOR STAFF
TO- AT THE F. T. V. TO PUT UP
ANAPPROPRIATE. DATA LIKE THAT
BY SKILLED THE BACK. BUT THIS
IS STILL A VERY VALUABLE
MEASURE AND WHAT IT DOES IS.
REQUIRES LARGE CORPORATIONS
THOSE WITH FIVE BILLION PLUS IN
GROCERY STREETS. TO DISCLOSE
ANNUALLY YES THREE DATA POINTS
NUMBER ONE THEIR NAME NUMBER
TWO THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF STATE
TAX VOTER PAID IN THAT YEAR.
AND THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF STATE
TAX CREDITS TAKEN NOW THIS IS
FAR LESS INFORMATION THAN WE
CAN ACCESS FEDERALLY AS A
RESULT OF THE DODD FRANK BILL
THE DODD FRANK BILL. REQUIRES
ALL PUBLICLY TRADED
CORPORATIONS IN THE US TO FILE
WITH THE SEC ANNUALLY AND GIVE
ALL KINDS OF INFORMATION
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL STATE TAX
PAID. THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS
THE AMOUNT OF THE CEOS PAY THE
GAP OR OR- DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
MEDIAN EMPLOYEE PAYING CEO PAY.
THIS BILL JUST GIVES US THE
SIMPLE INFORMATION I MENTIONED
FOR THE STATE BECAUSE OTHERWISE
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT KNOW. NOW
LET ME BE CLEAR SB NINE SEVEN
TWO DOES NOT RAISE TAXES NOT AT
ALL NOR DOES IT ELIMINATE ANY
TAX CREDIT OR EXPENDITURE IT
JUST GIVES US ACCESS TO
INFORMATION. THE F. T. B.'S
ESTIMATE IS THAT IT WOULD
AFFECT ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
CORPORATIONS THAT DO BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA THESE ARE NOT
JUST CORPORATIONS HEADQUARTERED
BUT ANY THAT DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH FIVE BILLION OR
ABOVE GROSS RECEIPTS. NOW THE
OPPOSITION CALLS THIS BILL
SHAMING BILL THAT IS NOT MY
PURPOSE. I CARRIED A BILL
SIMILAR TO THIS BACK IN THE
ORIGINAL RECESSION WHEN WE WERE
DEBATING WHETHER WE SHOULD
ELIMINATE CERTAIN TAX
EXPENDITURES WHETHER WE SHOULD
PUT IN NEW ONES. AND I AND MANY
OTHER PEOPLE FELT THAT WE JUST
DIDN'T HAVE ADEQUATE
INFORMATION THAT WHEN WE PASS
TAX CREDITS WE PASSED THEM FOR
GOOD PURPOSES. BUT MORE INFO
WOULD HELP US EVALUATE THEM NOW
THIS DOES NOT GO AS I MENTIONED
AS FAR AS I WOULD LIKE BUT HE
BEGINS TO GIVE US SOME BASIC
INFORMATION. AND IT ALSO WOULD
ALIGN US WITH SOME FIFTEEN
OTHER STATES SUCH AS FLORIDA
INDIANA MINNESOTA MISSISSIPPI
NEBRASKA AND OKLAHOMA ALL OF
WHICH REQUIRE CORPORATIONS
WITHIN. THAT STATE TO DISCLOSE
SIMILAR INFORMATION. SO BY WITH
THAT THE FINAL THING IS THIS
INFORMATION WOULD GO ON THE F.
T. B.'S WEBSITE AND AS I
MENTIONED IT DOES NOT ELIMINATE
TAX CREDITS AND IT DOES NOT
RAISE TAXES AND WITH THAT. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. ANY DESCRIPTION OR THE
BAIT. SENATOR DORADO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I BELIEVE THAT IF
WE'RE GONNA LEAD ON THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY ESPECIALLY
NOW THE CALIFORNIA MUST MAKE
SURE THAT OUR INVESTMENTS
BENEFIT CALIFORNIA WORKERS. I
THINK THAT THEY SHOULD PROVIDE
NEW JOBS CREATE NEW JOBS THEY
SHOULD PROVIDE FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGES BENEFITS
TRAINING AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS. TAX INCENTIVES
SHOULD REQUIRE COMPANIES TO
COMMIT. TO WORKER PROTECTIONS
ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS AND
TRAINING WITH ESPECIALLY FROM
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM THOSE KINDS OF
JOBS. COMPANIES I THINK SHOULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
COMMITMENTS THEY MAKE WHEN THEY
BENEFIT FROM OUR TAX DOLLARS.
TRANSPARENCY FOR OUR TAX
DOLLARS PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY
IS AN OBJECTIVE WAY FOR
ENFORCING THESE COMMITMENTS
HOWEVER PUBLIC OVERSIGHT ON
TAXPAYER DOLLARS HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN STYMIED. I
SUPPORT SB NINE SEVENTY TWO
BECAUSE IT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TO ENSURE RESPONSIBILITY WITH
OUR TAX DOLLARS THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF THE
BAY SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU
MAY POSE A QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR PLEASE CARTER TO
QUESTION YES. THANK YOU. AND I
WANNA MAKE CERTAIN NINE I
UNDERSTAND. THAT THIS REPORT
WILL BE MADE PUBLIC AND POSTED
ON THE WEBSITE F. T. BCS. IF
IT'S THE IDEA OF AUDITINGTO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT FROM A
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT THAT. ANY
INCENTIVES THAT THE GOVERNMENT
PROVIDES ANY CREDITS THAT ARE
RECEIVED BY THESE CORPORATIONS-
WITH THIS NOT BE. EASILY
AFFECTED THROUGH THE AUDIT
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE AT THE
COMMITTEE LEVEL THE ASSEMBLY OR
THE SENATE- INCORPORATED INTO.
THE NATURAL PROCESS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. PERMISSION TO FOR
FUTURE USE. IF YOU ARE
REFERRING TO THE STATE AUDITOR
AND TO- OR ABILITY TO THROUGH
THE AUDIT COMMITTEE APPROVED
THE STATE AUDITOR TO DO AUDITS-
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE STATE
AUDITOR ONLY HAS SO MUCH
CAPACITY AND I COULD BUT I
WOULD FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE THAT THAT THE COMMITTEE
OR EVEN THE LEGISLATURE
WHATEVER ASKED THE STATE
AUDITOR TO AUDIT. ALL SET FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES I THINK WHAT
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS AND-
DI DID NOT MENTION THAT IT DOES
NOT REVEAL ANY PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION. IS JUST TO GIVE US
THREE DATA POINTS THE NAME OF
THE COMPANY. THE MAITRE
MOUNTAINS STATE TAX PAID IN
TOTAL IN TOTAL THE NAME OUT OF
STATE TAX CREDITS PAID WE
ALREADY HAVE THAT INFORMATION
ABOUT THOSE SAME COMPANIES IN
TERMS OF WHAT. FEDERAL TAXES
THEY PAY AND WHAT FEDERAL STATE
OF FEDERAL CREDIT STATE TAKE
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE IT. FOR THE
STATE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO. NORMALLY WHEN I HEAR
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND MAKING
CERTAIN THAT IF CORPORATIONS-
RECEIVED PUBLIC BENEFITS OR
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS. I THINK
IT'S REASONABLE. TO ASK THAT
THAT BE DISCLOSED MY CONCERN IS
THAT POSTING IT ON THE WEBSITE
IN NOT SIMPLY BRING IT BACK TO-
THE POLICY MAKERS FOR FOLKS
WITHIN- THE GOVERNMENT FIELD.
MIGHT VIOLATE EXPECTATIONS OF
PRIVACY. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S
A BALANCE HERE ON WHETHER OR
NOT IT NEEDS TO BE MADE PUBLIC
AS OPPOSED TO IT BEING
INFORMATION THAT OTHERS CAN
ACCESS. DID YOU AS YOU WENT
THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO THAT
WITH THAT EVER CONSIDERED AS AN
OPTION- WAS CERTAINLY. THERE'S
ALWAYS THE CONSIDERATION OF
WHAT LEVEL OF STAFF TIME IS
REQUIRED AND GIVEN THAT WE ARE
IN DEFICIT. MODE IN MAY BE
ASKING OUR STATE EMPLOYEES TO
FOR LOW AND SUCH. WE WERE
TRYING TO DESIGN A BILL THAT
WOULD PUT THE LEAST PHONE-
AMOUNT OF STAFF. TIME
REQUIREMENT AND SO BY THE EASE
OF PUTTING IT UP ONCE ONE
ANNUALLY. THEN WE ALL HAVE THE
ACCESS THE INFORMATION ANYTIME
WE WANTED VERSUS HAVING TO
REQUESTED FROM STAFF AND HAVING
STAFF HAVE TO PRODUCE THAT
INFORMATION EACH TIME IT EACH
INDIVIDUAL REQUEST. THIS IS
MORE EFFICIENT. A SINNER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT- JUST A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR. THERE MAY WITH THE
AUTHOR EXCERPTED QUESTION YES.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ENACTED
THE TAXPAYERS BILL OF RIGHTS
AND IT- ALSO RE ENACTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN. DO WE
NEED TO MODIFY THE TAX PAYERS
BILL OF RIGHTS OR- ARE WE SORT
OF. OPENING A DOOR FOR MORE
MORE CHANGES IN THERE FOR MAYBE.
GOING BACK ON A COMMITMENT THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE MAY. WITH
PERMISSION TO THE TEACHER HE-
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE. ANY
TAX FILING TO BE DISCLOSED SO
THE FIVE HUNDRED APPROXIMATELY
AT A STRIP BY FTV COMPANIES
THAT ARE IMPACTED DO NOT HAVE
TO. GIVE PUBLICLY OR DISCLOSE
THEIR ACTUAL TAX FILING SOLELY
AND ONLY THE THREE DATA POINTS
THAT I GAVE SO IN THAT RESPECT
IT IS NOT AN INTERFERENCE WITH
THE TAXPAYER BILL OF RIGHTS
STATUTES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM I SEE NO FURTHER
MIKE'S CENTER SKINNER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE BY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA. ATKINS I
BATES NO BELL. I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM.
CHIANG NO DALLY NO DODD. THERE
ARE SO. I GALGIANI NO GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL HI HUESO I TADO. JACKSON
FIVE JONES. NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE
AYE MELINDA'S. NO MITCHELL I
MONNING I MORE LOCK. NO MORE
AROUND. NO NIELSEN. NO HAN. I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. RIGHT I
REVIEW. I SKINNER I STERN I
NUMBER I WAKE OWSKI. I WIENER I
WILK NO SECTOR PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I GORGEOUS NO CUT BY
ADAM. DODD I GLAZER TADO. RICE
TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TWELVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MARINO NOW TO
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE BY SENATOR
WIENER HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE OH TWO BY SENATOR
WIENER AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE- WINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATE BILL NINE OH
TO- PROVIDE CITIES WITH A
POWERFUL NEW VOLUNTARY TOOL. TO
ALLOW THEM IF THEY WANT TO- TWO
BY ZONE FOR INCREASED DENSITY
UP TO TEN YEAR TO APARTMENT
BUILDINGS AND WHEREVER THEY
DEEM APPROPRIATE AND THEIR CITY
AS LONG AS IT IS NOT SPRAWL
MUST BE AN INFILL AREA. OR NEAR
TRANSIT OR IN A JOB RICH AREA-
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE. MANY
CITIES THAT ONE HIS OWN FOR
MORE DENSITY AND PORTIONS OF
THEIR CITY- BUT WE MAKE IT
UNDER STATE LAW TAKE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TIME IT CAN
TAKE YEARS AND YEARS. EVEN FIVE
OR TEN YEARS FOR CITY TO DO
WHAT WE WANT THEM TO DO WHICH
IS HIS OWN FOR MORE HOUSING. I
KNOW SB NINE OH TWO WILL
PROVIDE FOR THIS LADY FORMER
DENSITY UP TO TEN UNITS PER
PARCEL OF TO TENURE BUILDINGS
WILL GIVE CITIES AN EXPEDITED
STREAMLINED WAY TO BE ABLE TO
DO THE ZONING QUICKLY THIS'LL
BE OF GREAT USE TO CITIES AS A
RESULT GOING FORWARD WITH THE
HIGHER. STATE HOUSING THAT ARE
HIGH PAYING- THIS IS A LOCAL.
BILL BUT IT'S ALSO A LOCAL
EMPOWERMENT BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I. BUT-
HE ANY QUESTIONS OR OR DEBATE.
IN A DISCUSSION OR DEBATE BY
MEMBERS. SEEN NO MICROPHONES
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA OR AYE
ATKINS. I BATES NO WELL I
FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE A-
CHIANG. VALLEY DODD. HI THERE
EITHER. GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
I HILL I HUESO. I TADO I
JACKSON. JONES I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK
BY MORALE. NIELSEN PAN. I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN I AMBER BUT I
Y. CASKEY. I WIENER I WILK NO.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN FOR JUST.
I CABALLERO I CHIANG HI DOLLY.
FIVE DORADO. MORE JACKSON.
MERLE NIELSEN I. PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS RUMER TIME.
ALLEN THERE ARE THERE. JACKSON
MORAL. PRICE THIRTY THREE KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW MEMBERS TO FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO SENATOR
PORTANTINO ARE YOU PREPARED. HE
IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
REALLY SENATE BILL NINE
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AN AXE RELATING TO FIRE ARMS
CENTER PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
THAT I AM PRESENTING SB NINE
FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
VERIFY THE VALIDITY OF HUNTING
LICENCES WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE WHEN A PERSON
IS UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE.
IS USING THE LICENSE TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM WE ALL SAW
THE TRAGIC. SHOOTING IN THE POW
A SYNAGOGUE. WHERE ANY TEENAGER
USED. ON IMPROPER HUNTING
LICENSE TO ACQUIRE A WEAPON
PRIOR TO THAT CRIME THIS BILL
SEEKS. TO CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE-
AND CLEAN UP CODE SECTIONS AND
CROSS REFERENCES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE UNDER
CURRENT LAW. WHEN TRANSFERRING
A PURCHASE A FIREARM WITH A
HUNTING LICENSE THERE'S NO
VERIFICATION PROCESS DURING THE
TEN DAY BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS TO ENSURE THE VALIDITY
OF THE LICENSE. THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THE OUTSTANDING
CIRCUMSTANCES I'M COVERED IN
POWER WAY AS I MENTION AND FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DESCRIPTION INVADE ON THIS ITEM
HEARING SEEN NONE. OF THEM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. I
BATES NO BELL I FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM. I
CHIANG NO DALLY NO DODD. I
DORADO. I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
I HIL I HUESO OR I TADO. I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL.
I MONNING. HI WARLOCK. MORRELL
NO NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN I NUMBER HI MY
CAO SKI. I WIENER. FIVE WILK NO.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THAT'S A MEMBER. MORE LIKE.
MORE LIKE NOW. VICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NINETY THREE SENATOR
JACKSON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY
SIX BY SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION SENATE
JACKSON FOR GEORGE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES TO
SERVE BILL MAY SOUND FAMILIAR
IN THAT IT WAS SIMILAR TO ONE
THAT I BROUGHT LAST YEAR. IT
ALSO ADDRESSES THE QUESTION OF
TAX EXPENDITURES WHICH MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE- FROM BERKELEY HAS
SO- JUST- PRESENTED ON THE
FLOOR. IF I GIVE YOU A DOLLAR
ON THE PROMISE THAT YOU WILL
GIVE ME BACK FIVE. THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A PRETTY GOOD DEAL. BUT IF
I GIVE YOU A DOLLAR ON THE
PROMISE YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE ME
BACK FIVE BUT YOU ONLY GIVE ME
BACK TWENTY FIVE CENTS THAT'S
NOT A GOOD DEAL. AND SO FOR
YEARS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE HAD THE SO
CALLED TAX EXPENDITURES. WHICH
WOULD HAVE BEEN TAX CREDITS TAX
BREAKS TAX INCENTIVES. WHICH
HAVE BEEN DESIGNED FOR VARIOUS
DIFFERENT PURPOSES. SOME OF
THEM TO ENCOURAGE BUSINESSES
SOME OF THEM TO ENCOURAGE
BETTER TREATMENT IN THE WORK
FORCE FOR A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT REASONS. THE PROBLEM
IS THAT MANY OF THESE TAX
EXPENDITURES ARE FIFTY SIXTY
YEARS OLD. AND THEY'VE NEVER
BEEN ANALYZED SO THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WILL BRING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO SOME OF OUR STAGE MOST
COSTLY TAX INCENTIVES BY
CREATING THAT PROCESS FOR THEIR
ANALYSIS AND PUBLIC REVIEW.
THIS MEASURE ALLOWS THE%
LEGISLATURE THROUGH RIGOROUS
ANALYSIS THE INVOLVEMENT OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
RECOMMENDATION OF AN
INDEPENDENT FIVE MEMBER BOARD
TO DETERMINE IF HESE TAX
EXPENDITURES. ARE COST
EFFECTIVE IMPROPERLY DESIGNED
WHETHER THEY ARE EFFECTIVELY
MEETING THEIR INTENDED PUBLIC
POLICY OBJECTIVES AND ARE
WORTHY OF BEING CONTINUED. THIS
IS BY SECTOR BY INDUSTRY WE'RE
NOT CALLING OUT ANY PARTICULAR
COMPANY WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE TRYING TO DETERMINE
WHETHER SOME OF THESE TAX
INCENTIVES REALLY MAKES SENSE
TODAY. AND IF THEY DO MAKE
SENSE FOR EXAMPLE THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY TAX
CREDIT BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
ONE OF OUR FORMER COLLEAGUES
SHE INTRODUCED LEGISLATION THAT
REQUIRES TRUST SUCH A PROCESS
THAT I'VE IDENTIFIED HERE. FOR
ALL NEW TAX INCENTIVES THAT
WERE CREATED FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN ON ONE OF THEM WAS THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY TAX
CREDIT. REQUIRED THE INDUSTRY
TO COME FORWARD OVER A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME AND DEMONSTRATE
THAT THE INCENTIVES WE HAD
GIVEN THEM WERE IN FACT
RETURNING FIVE DOLLARS OR FOUR
DOLLARS PER DOLLAR WE GAVE THEM
IN TAX CREDITS WHAT WE
DISCOVERED WHAT IN FACT. IT WAS
WORKING SO WELL THAT WE
ACTUALLY INCREASED THE
INCENTIVE. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
IDEA THOUGH ABOUT THESE TAX
INCENTIVES THAT WERE CREATED
BEFORE. TWENTY FOURTEEN. SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS MEASURE WILL
DO IT WILL. TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
EIGHTY TAX BREAKS OR ACTUALLY
IT'S ONLY GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT ABOUT NINE OF THEM BUT WE
HAVE EIGHTY OF THEM THAT EVERY
YEAR COSTS THIS STATE UP TO
SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS. NOW IF
YOU TAKE 40% OF THAT LET'S SAY
THEY AREN'T WORKING. YOU TAKE
40% OF THAT THAT'S TWENTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS THERE WOULD GO
TO EDUCATION. LET'S SAY MOST OF
THEM ARE WORKING IN OUR
PROVIDING US WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS WE HAD WHEN WE
INTRODUCE THEM. AT LEAST WE
WILL KNOW THAT WE ARE RECEIVING
THAT BENEFIT BUT IF WE ARE NOT.
THIS MEASURE CALLS FOR AN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS BY THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. IT THEN
CALLS FOR AN INDEPENDENT REVIEW
BOARD. WHICH WILL ANALYZE THE
INFORMATION AND PRESENTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE. SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE INFORMATION
POLICIES OF THE STATE WANT TO
CONTINUE WITH THOSE CREDITS.
THIS IS JUST GOOD GOVERNANCE
AND IN FACT THE LA- SEVERAL
YEARS AGO TWENTY FIFTEEN SHOULD
WE DON'T DO THOSE FOLKS AND WE
REALLY SHORT. IN FACT THERE ARE
MANY OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
DONE THIS STATES LIKE TEXAS
LOUISIANA NORTH DAKOTA
MISSISSIPPI AND INDIANA. FOR
EXAMPLE DO THESE EXACT KINDS OF
ANALYSES AND DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE GETTING THE BANG
FOR THEIR BUCK THAT THEY EXPECT
AND BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE OF
THEIR STATE SHOULD HAVE THAT'S
WHAT THIS MEASURE DOES. AND
WITH THAT ARE AGAIN LOOKING AT
OUR BUDGET DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE
IF THERE IS MONEY THAT CAN AND
SHOULD COME BACK TO THE STATE
WE SHOULD KNOW ABOUT IT IF WE
SHOULD BE INVESTING EVEN MORE
WE KNOW ABOUT IT THE FACT IS WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO DO. WITH IT BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
YOU DISCUSS AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SCHIRMER. RESHAPE BEEN
ABLE BE HERE ARMED. ARE YOU
KNOW A WITH IN LIGHT OF THE
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT- I'M COMMITTED TO
LIMITED CONSTITUTIONAL
GOVERNMENT NOT EXPANDING
GOVERNMENT WHICH WE DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK WE HAVE OVER
SIX HUNDRED GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT AND NOW WE WANT TO
CREATE AOTHER BUREAUCRACY-
WHICH IS JUST GONNA COST MORE
MONEY TO TAXPAYERS AND IT'S
INTERESTING THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE FOR THIS BILL SUPPORTED OUR
COURSE UNIONS WHO ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR AS- THERE B. L. AN
INCREASE. FUNDING FOR. HIGHER
RETIREMENTS AND HIGHER WAGES
AND THAT TYPE OF THING SO I'M
OPPOSED TO IT AGAIN BECAUSE I'M
NOT IN FAVOR. OF OCT EXPANDING.
THE ALREADY. OVER BUREAUCRATIC
STATE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
SEEN NINE SENATOR JACKSON WILL
TALK TO CLOSE. KATE THAT THE-
THANK YOU THAT THE OUR BOARD
SUNSET SIX MONTHS AFTER THAT
IT'S PRESENTED ITS REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE BUT IF I'M
GOING TO SIT DOWN AND LEARN
THAT THAT ONE DOLLAR I'M GIVING
YOU IS ONLY RETURNING TWENTY
FIVE CENTS THAT'S GOOD
GOVERNMENT. BECAUSE AND I'M
GONNA STOP BUT IF IT'S GIVEN ME
BACK FIVE BUCKS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR PUT IN THAT'S GOOD
GOVERNMENT AND THAT IS WHAT
WITH THE PUBLIC AND THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE ABLE TO
EXPECT AND RELY UPON US TO
PRODUCE. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. OR AYE ATKINS. FIVE
EIGHT NO BELL I FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A. NO CHIANG.
NO DALLY NO DODD. I DORADO I
GALGIANI NO GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I HILL I
HUESO. I TADO. JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. FIVE MONNING. I
MORE LOCK MORRELL NO NIELSEN.
NO HAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH.
I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN. I
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY. I WIENER. I
WILK NOW. I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALLED UP TO MEMBERS. GLAZER
TADO. MORE LOCK NO. MARCH
TWENTY FIVE MILLS THIRTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR
SKINNER ONE. WIENER YOU FOR
SENATORS HERE'S A WINNER ARE
YOU PREPARED. I'M SORRY.
BROWN'S SECTOR PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR WINNER AND ACTUALLY
DID A HOUSING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT CALLED
THE SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT- WILL ENSURE THAT CITIES
ARE ZONING FOR- AND ALLOWING
SHELTER FOR HOMELESS RESIDENTS
BY ELEVEN SIR SB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT ALSO INSURANCE TIMELY
ADOPTION OF A HOUSING ELEMENT-
WERE- WHICH RIGHT NOW THERE IS
A LOOPHOLE THAT IS ALLOWING
CITIES TO GO YEARS AND YEARS.
WITHOUT ADOPTING A HOUSING
ELEMENT OUR COLLEAGUES NEARLY
70% OF CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS
POPULATION- IS ON OUR STREETS.
HI WHEN YOU LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION WE ARE
LESS THAN FIFTEEN PERCENT. OF
THE NATION'S POPULATION BUT ONE
HALF OF ALL ON SHELTER HOMELESS
PEOPLE. ARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S NOT JUST
RANDOM AND IT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND
IT'S A MORAL FAILURE BY OUR
STATE. EVERY CALIFORNIA AND
WITH OR WITHOUT OUSING
DESERVES TO BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT. AND THIS
IS A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY.
UNDER EXISTING HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW CITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
DESIGNATE A ZONE AND THERE CITY
WERE HOMELESS SHELTERS CAN BE
PERMITTED AS OF RIGHT. THIS IS
ADOPTED YEARS AGO IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A PART OF A CITY WHERE
YOU CAN CITE A HOMELESS SHELTER
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH A
CONDITIONAL USE PROCESS WITHOUT
HAVING TO HAVE ALL SORTS OF
FIGHTS AND LITIGATION. HOWEVER
SOME CITIES ARE DESIGNATING A
ZONE. IN AN AREA AREAS WERE
KNOWN WHATEVER BUILD A HOMELESS
SHELTER ON THE FAR OUTSKIRTS OF
THE CITY FAR AWAY FROM ANY
TRANSPORTATION OR SERVICES. IN
AN INDUSTRIAL AREA IN THE
MIDDLE OF NO WHERE. WERE YOU
KNOW WHATEVER SAID A HOMELESS
SHELTER OR IN AN AREA WHERE IT
IS PHYSICALLY POSSIBLE TO
ACTUALLY SO YOU ONE BECAUSE IT
IS ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. BUILT
OUT. SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
WILL REQUIRE- DIED IN HIS OWN
THAT'S DESIGNATED CITIES WILL
STILL HAVE ENORMOUS FLEXIBILITY
WHERE IT'S A DESIGNATED. BUT IT
WILL REQUIRE THAT IT NOT BE IN
A REMOTE INDUSTRIAL AREA THAT'D
BE- GEOGRAPHICALLY CONNECTED TO
EITHER TRANSIT OR SERVICES.
SOMEWHERE WHERE PEOPLEWOULD
ACTUALLY BUILD A SHELTER IN
ADDITION A CANNOT BE IN AN AREA
WHERE IT'S PHYSICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE. TO ACTUALLY SITES
SHELTER IN ADDITION A STILL IN
THIRTY IT CLOSES A LOOPHOLE
THAT SOME CITIES ARE USING. TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A DRAFT HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT NEVER ACTUALLY
GETS APPROVED. CREATING BETTER
INCENTIVES FOR CITIES TO
ACTUALLY COMPLETE THE HOUSING
IMPROPER. AND TO APPROVE IT OUR
RISK. OUT AND I'VE- THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSS CENTER MY- THANK YOU
I'M LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. THE
REASON THAT WE HAVE SUCH AN
ENORMOUS HOMELESS POPULATION IN
THIS STATE IS BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES THAT COME OUT OF THIS
BUILDING. IT'S NOT BECAUSE
SOMETHING THE LOCALS DID IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE LAWS AND THE
POLICIES THAT ARE PUT OUT BY
THE PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING
SPECIFICALLY THE MAJORITY PARTY
HAS BEEN RUNNING THIS STATE
INTO THE GROUND FOR THE LAST
MANY YEARS SO I DON'T THINK
IT'S FAIR OR JUST. TO PUSH THE
PROBLEM DOWN ON TO THE TO SAY
PLEASE FIX THE PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE CREATED THAT DOESN'T SEEM
EQUITABLE TO ME. SO I THINK IT
RATHER THAN SOLUTION IS TO NOT
BREATHE DOWN THE NEXT OF THE
LOCALS AND TELL THEM WHERE
HOMELESS SHELTERS SHOULD BE BUT
ALLOW THEM TO MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES UNLESS
OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO PUT
POLICIES OUT. FROM THIS
BUILDING. THAT DO SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESS POPULATION
AND HOMELESS PROBLEM RATHER
THAN EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE- TIME AFTER TIME YEAR
AFTER YEAR WE PASS BILLS. THAT
MAKE THE COST OF LIVING MORE
EXPENSIVE IN CALIFORNIA. WE'VE
INCREASED THE COST OF LITERALLY
EVERYTHING IN THE STATE TO THE
POINT. WHERE WE'VE HAD FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS LEAVE THE
STATE LAST DECADE BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD IT. AND THOSE WHO
CAN'T MOVE HAD MOVED TO THE
STREETS. THAT'S THE FAULT OF
THE POLICIES COMING OUT OF THIS
BUILDING NOT THE FAULT OF THE
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS I WOULD
URGE YOU KNOW ABOUT. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR BORCHERS.
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MISS PRESENT CENTER WHEN WE
TAKE A QUESTION AS TO A FUTURE
FOR THE CHAIR THEN THANK YOU.
PRIOR TO MY EXPERIENCE IN
SACRAMENTO I SERVE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND MY RECOLLECTION
IS YOU DID TO. ON BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- HAVING SERVED ON
THE CITY COUNCIL AND THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. ALL USE FRESNO
IS AN EXAMPLE ONE OF THE- MOST
HOTLY DEBATED ISSUES IS WHERE
TO PUT A SHELTER. AND WHAT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS THERE
MORE THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO FIND AN
ACCEPTABLE LOCATION BUT IT'S
INEVITABLY TURNING INTO A DOG
FIGHT MY CONCERN IS THAT
FORCING THIS. THAT THE HOUSING
PLAN- BE STATUTORILY ARE THE
TIME PERIOD WITHIN WHICH THE
STATUTORILY DECREASED IF THEY
DON'T IS OF CONCERN TO ME. AS
THIS IS GOING THROUGH THE
VARIOUS COMMITTEE PROCESS USED
WAS THAT EVER SOMETHING THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE CONSIDERED
REMOVING. AS A AS A AS A
PROVISION SO. AT THE PRESENT
PLEASE. WHICH IS TO BE CLEARER-
TO THE- US TO CENTER FROM UP
FRESNO COUNTY- V. THERE ARE WO
PARTS OF THE BILL AND THE TWO
PARTS ARE NOT AND THEY'RE NOT
ALL BOTH ABOUT HOMELESS
SHELTERS. THERE'S A ONE PART
THE TAKE EXISTING LAW FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS CITIES ARE
REQUIRED WHEN THEY DO THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT TO DESIGNATE A
BY RIGHT ZONE FOR HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND THIS SIMPLY PUTS
MORE PARAMETERS AROUND THAT.
FOR THE CITIES ARE PUTTING IT
OUT YOU KNOW TWENTY MILES AWAY
FROM ANY SERVICES OR TRANSIT OR
ANYTHING ELSE WERE NO WHATEVER
BILL THE SHELTER THAT'S THE ONE
PIECE WERE SIMPLY PUTTING
GUARDRAILS AROUND AN EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS. THE SECOND PIECE
IS NOT A SPECIFIC TO HOMELESS
SHELTERS IT'S ABOUT SIMPLY
ADOPTING A HOUSING ELEMENT TO
BEGIN WITH EVERY CITY AND
COUNTY HAS TO ADOPT. A HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT'S LONG FIFTY YEAR
STATE LAW. ON BUT WE DON'T HAVE
STRONG GUARDRAILS NOW ABOUT
ACTUALLY ADOPTING A IN A TIMELY
WAY AND SO CITIES WILL HAVE A
DRAFT HOUSING ELEMENT THAT'S
NEVER BEEN ACTUALLY APPROVED.
AND I WILL GO ON FOR YEARS AND
YEARS AND SO THE BILL PUTS IN
STRONGER INCENTIVES. TO SAID
THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE YOUR
ADOPTED HOUSING ELEMENT WITHIN
FOUR MONTHS OF THE DEADLINE SO
NOT EVEN BY THE DEADLINE.
WITHIN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS AFTER THE DEADLINE YOU
NEED TO HAVE A DOCTOR TO AND IF
YOU DON'T DOZEN THERE'S A
SHORTER TIME FRAME FOR DOING
THE RECALL REZONING UNDER THE
POLICY ON THAT. SO ONE IS ABOUT
HOMELESS SHELTERS ONE IS ABOUT
HOUSING ELEMENTS IN GENERAL. I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
CORRECTLY. I THINK THE- THE
IDEA OF A HALF OF APPROVING A
HOUSING ELEMENT. IS ONE WAS
CONTROVERSIAL. ASPECTS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND I THINK HAVING.
THE HOMELESS ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. GOES INTO THE
HOUSING ELEMENT IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN. THE. IS THAT CORRECT
FOR THE PRESIDENT THE- SENATE
BOOK BORDERS ARE YOU ASKING
ANOTHER QUESTION THIS IS TYLER
CODES OF FOLLOW UP TO THE FIRST
QUESTION MISTER PRESIDENT AND
ALL STOP HERE. ARE THE UNDER
SOMETHING LIKE TWENTY YEAR OLD
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW CITIES HAVE
TO IDENTIFY HIS OWN WITHIN THE
CITY EXACTLY WHERE A HOUSING
WERE HOMELESS SHELTER CAN BE
APPROVED AS OF RIGHT SO WE
DON'T WAS SO WE STOP HAVING 70%
OF HOMELESS PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA SLEEPING ON THE
STREETS INSTEAD OF SLEEPING IN
A SHELTER AND SO THE- BILL.
PROVIDES THAT YOU CAN'T DAM
THAT REQUIRE MEN BY LOCATING A
TWENTY EIGHT MILES OUTSIDE OF
TOWN WHERE HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE
NEVER GOING TO BE EVEN
PHYSICALLY ABLE TO GO HOMELESS
PEOPLE DON'T TO FOR SOME HAVE
CARS BECAUSE THEY SLEEP IN
THEIR CARS OTHERS DON'T AND
IT'S ABOUT PUTTING GARDRAILS
AROUND THAT YES IT'S
CONTROVERSIAL THAT'S WHY THIS
LAW WAS WRITTEN TWENTY YEARS
AGO. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR GLAZER.
I'M ON THE MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I GUESS A AND IT'S A
QUESTION AND THE AUTHOR CAN
ANSWER TO DISCLOSE IF HE WISHES
BUT THESE HOW THE ELEMENTS ARE
THINGS THAT CHANGE THAT THERE'S
THE FIFTH CYCLE THE SIX PACK OF
WHO KNOWS WHAT COMES. AND I
HAVE HEARD FROM BY CITIES HAVE
CHALLENGING IT IS. TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLY BECAUSE YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT'S COMING AROUND
THE CORNER. NEXT YEAR. AND SO
I'M HOPING THAT- HE COULD SPEAK
TO THAT- ISSUE OF THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. TO COMPLY
BECAUSE- THAT THAT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR THE FULLY. FOR
SMALLER COMMUNITIES. THE SECOND
QUESTION WOULD BE THAT. I DON'T
SEE THE LEAGUE OF CITIES HAS
WAITED ON THIS LEGISLATION AND
I WAS HOPING YOU COULD SHARE
WITH US THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
HAVE HAD WITH THEM SO THAT WE
CAN BE ELIMINATED BY THAT
CONVERSATION WHERE IT HAS
LANDED. LIGHTLY. SO I. OF THE
PRESENT. ON SECRET. I DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES LEAGUE OF CITIES HAS
NOT. TO MY KNOWLEDGE OPPOSED-
THIS BILL- I'VE NOT SEEN IT- AT
LEAST- BECAUSE THIS BILL IS NOT
ANY KIND OF. DICEY IT IS IT IS
A BELT AND SUSPENDERS. APPROACH
TO SAYING WE HAVE THIS HOUSING
ELEMENT REQUIREMENTS FOR FIFTY
YEARS. ALWAYS SAY TO CITIES IS
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
PLANNING PROCESS AND PLAN FOR
GROWTH. AND PLAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO SLEEP
IN THEIR CARS AND WE HAVE
ENOUGH HOUSING. FOR PEOPLE. HI
AND OVER TIME UNFORTUNATELY
WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE CITIES
THAT AVOID THAT REQUIREMENT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS- AND SOMETIMES
DON'T EVEN APPROVED A HOUSING
ELEMENT ALL WERE WERE PROVE IT
YEARS. LADY AND SO WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO SAY WE HAVE THIS
REQUIREMENT EDITION MEANS
SOMETHING- SO THAT THAT'S
REALLY. THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT NOW IN TERMS OF
RESOURCES I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE- IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE TO STOP OP ESPECIALLY FOR
SMALL CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE.
THE GENERAL FUND LIKE A LOS
ANGELES OR SAN FRANCISCO- OR IN
OAKLAND TO BE ABLE TO HELP AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE NINE. AND
SENATE BILL TWO THAT WAS
AUTHORED BY OUR- PRO TEM-
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THERE IS A
POT OF MONEY IN SENATE BILL
TWO. OR PLANNING GRANTS FOR
CITIES. FOUND IN ADDITION AND I
KNOW IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
OBVIOUSLY THE BUDGET SO
DIFFERENT POSITION THIS YEAR
BUT IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S FIRST
PROPOSED BUDGET THAT WE AGREED
WITH. WE PUT ADDITIONAL FUNDS
INTO THE BUDGET TO PROVIDE
PLANNING GRANTS FOR CITIES FOR
SMALLER CITIES TO HELP THEM
GROW THROUGH THEIR- YOU KNOW
THE CITIES THAT HAVE AN
UPDATED- ZONING AND FORTY OR
FIFTY YEARS I NEED HELP WITH A
HOUSING ELEMENT. SO WE HAVE
STEPPED UP AS THE STATE I'M
SURE WE CAN ALWAYS DO MORE BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING WHERE I FULLY
AGREE WITH THE SENATOR FROM
AROUND THE- THIS PRESIDENT ON
MY OWN TIME I KNOW THE AUTHOR'S
HEART IS IN THE RIGHT PLACE AND
HE IDENTIFIES. AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I SHARE. THE GOALS
THAT HE HAS AND I GUESS I WOULD
SAY GOING FORWARD I HOPE THAT-
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO LOOK INTO
THIS ISSUE OF FUNDING YES THERE
WAS RESOURCES PUT ASIDE BUT ARE
THEY THERE. AND AS WE KNOW
THESE HOUSING ELEMENTS KEEP
COMING AROUND EVERY FOUR TO.
EIGHT YEARS- THERE CREATING
STRESSFUL THAT'S NOT BECAUSE-
EXTENT NECESSARILY OF WHAT'S
BEEN REQUIRED BUT WHAT THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT'S
GOING TO BE REQUIRED. AND
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SET CLEAR
DEADLINES. IT COULD BE
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE EMERGENCY
SHELTER ISSUE BUT SIMPLY. OTHER
LIMITATIONS THAT HAVE A FLOATER
CITIES. IN THEIR ABILITY TO SO.
COMPLY AS IT'S DEFINED SO I
WOULD ASSESS AS YOU GO FORWARD
TO. CONSIDER WAYS IN WHICH YOU
CAN HELP THOSE WHO ARE TRYING
TO DO THEIR BEST WORK- GIVEN
THE LIMITED RESOURCES THAT
THEY- MAY HAVE AT THEIR
DISPOSAL. SINGER MORLOCK. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS REFERRING TO ARE SB
TWO ZONES. EVERY CITY AS A
GENERAL PLAN IN EVERY GENERAL
PLAN SHOULD INCLUDE AN SP TWO
ZONE WHERE YOU CAN HAVE A YEAR
ROUND. HOMELESS SHELTER. THAT'S
IN THE LAW CURRENTLY. THE
TROUBLE IS BEEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. FOR CITY
COUNCIL IS TO FIND A LOCATION-
IT HAS BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT
TASK BOB AS A FORMER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR MYSELF- WE LOCATED A
FACILITY IN THE CITY OF
FULLERTON. AND OPEN THE ESCROW
ONLY THEN TO HAVE THE CITY
COUNCIL BE BOMBARDED AND
PRESSURED HIM BY ONE VOTE WE
LOST THAT FACILITY VERY
DIFFICULT TIME THE THEN WORKED
WITH THE CITY OF SANTA ANA. TRY
TO GET THEM TO FIND A FACILITY
OR LOCATION THEY PICK THE SITE
THAT BAFFLED ME BUT IT WASN'T
CLOSE TO WHERE THE HOMELESS
WERE BUT THEN ALL THE NEIGHBORS
AROUND THAT. SITE THAT WE
OPENED ESCROW ON- CONVINCED THE
CITY COUNCIL THAT. THAT
WOULDN'T WORK SO WE LOST THAT
OPPORTUNITY. WE FINALLY FIND A
LOCATION IN THE CITY OF ANAHEIM
CLOSE TO THE FREEWAY AND- NOW
YOU WOULD EVEN KNOW WAS THERE
IF YOU DIDN'T. GET OFTEN DRIVE
AROUND BUT IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN
A WELL RUN FACILITY. BUT THIS
IS A DIFFICULT ASSIGNMENT FOR
CITY COUNCILS. SMALL CITIES
I'VE HAD HIM IN MY OFFICE AND
I'VE ASKED THEM IN LA COUNTY.
WE'RE LIKE LOW MEDIA WHERE
WHERE IS YOUR- SB TO ZONE THEY
SAY WELL WE'RE ONLY A SQUARE
MILE. WE DON'T EVEN HAVE A
PLACE WE COULD PUT A HOMELESS
SHELTER. AS WELL THEN WHERE ARE
YOU BRINGING YOUR HOMELESS
PEOPLE. TO THE CITY NEXT DOOR
THEY HAVE A SHELTER THEN. ARE
YOU REIMBURSING THEM AT ALL FOR
THE COSTS CAN YOU. COOPERATE
TOGETHER SO THAT YOUR SB TWO
ZONE IS ACTUALLY BEING MET BY A
NEIGHBORING CITY BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
LANDER OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
FOR AN SP TWO ZONE. SO WITH
THAT. I AGREE WITH THE SENATE
PURMEREND OF WHAT CAN WE DO.
THANK COURAGE. OUR CITIES AND-
YOU KNOW HONORING THE SP TWO
ZONE WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
THE HOMELESS AND THERE ARE SOME
INCREDIBLE MODELS. AROUND THIS
STATE AND AROUND THIS COUNTRY
AND I VISITED PLENTY OF THEM
BUT HOW DO WE HELP. CITY
COUNCILS TO ADDRESS THE
REACTION AND HOW DO WE SHOW
THEM. THAT THEY CAN WORK NEXT
TO CERTAIN AREAS IT IT'S OUR
MESSAGING IT'S A COMMUNICATION
ANSWER PERSUADING ISSUE AND SO-
WE HAVE WE HAVE- ARMORIES THAT
ARE OPEN IN THE WINTER. AND IN
SANTA ANA THE NEIGHBOR SAID
WELL WE DON'T WANT THIS WE
DON'T KNOW HOMELESS SHELTER
BECAUSE THIS NEXT TO THE
SCHOOLS. WELL THE ARMORY THE
FENCE ABOUT THE SCHOOL AND IN
THIS GOING ON FOR DECADES AND
NO ONE HAS EVER. MADE AN ISSUE
THAT IS SO IF IT'S WELL RUN AND
IT'S WELL MANAGED. IT ALL WORKS
SO I WOULD JUST. REPEAT WHAT
THE SENATOR FROM ORINDA. SAID
IS. WE NEED TO ONE WE GET IT WE
GOT IT ENCOURAGE THEM TO COMPLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT COMPLYING
BUT TO HOW DO WE HELP THEM. IN
THAT ENDEAVOR SO THAT IT ISN'T.
OVERBEARING BUT IT'S COMING UP
UNDER ME EVEN HELPING THESE
CITIES TO MEET THIS CRITICAL
NEED AND SO I I'M I'M I'M WITH
THE BILL I WAS THERE IN
COMMITTEE. I THINK THIS HAS TO
BE DONE IT'S IT SHOULD BE A
LOCAL LEPER BUT BUT WE SHOULD
SEE HOW WE CAN BE THERE TO HELP
OUT THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF THE RATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEN NO MORE MIKE'S UP
SOONER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER PRESS OFFICER
TO DO. OF ALL THE I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER PRESIDENT OF
FIRST OF ALL BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE THIS DEBATE. IT'S A
GOOD THING WHEN WE HAVE A
ROBUST DEBATE ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS ON THE FLOOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T DEBATED AT
AN OFFICE WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO
THE HEART OF THE MATTER
ANNOUNCED AND WE HAVE AN
ARTICLE WE GRAPPLED. WITH THE
ABSOLUTE TRAGEDY. AN
EMBARRASSMENT FOR THE STATE
THAT AS I MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING THAT ONE HALF 50% OF
ALL ON SHELTERED AMERICANS. OUR
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ONE HALF OF ALL ON
SHELTERED HOMELESS PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
ARE RESIDENTS OF THE
PROGRESSIVE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND RESISTANCE TO
HOMELESS SHELTERS. IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE THERE ARE
PARTISAN ISSUES IN THIS BODY
THIS ISN'T ONE OF THEM. I WILL
TELL YOU THAT RESISTANCE TO
HOMELESS SHELTERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS EVERY BIT AS
INTENSE. TO RESISTANCE IN
ORANGE COUNTY OR FRESNO COUNTY
OR LOS ANGELES OR ANYWHERE ELSE
THERE IS NO PLACE IN THIS STATE
THAT I'M AWARE OF. WHERE PEOPLE
GET UP AND SAY PLEASE BRING A
HOMELESS SHELTER AND TO MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. I'M I CAME UP
THROUGH A NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION AND THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND I HAVE SEEN. THE
UGLINESS OF IT EVERYONE EVEN
OUR MOST PROGRESSIVE BASTIONS
IN THIS STATE. TALK ABOUT THE
TALK A GOOD GAME. ABOUT SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS BUT WHEN IT COMES
TIME TO DO SOMETHING. NOT HERE.
THIS ISN'T THE RIGHT
NEIGHBORHOOD FOR A PUT IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND ALL OUR
STATE LAW DOES ALL WE'RE ASKING.
IS JUST DESIGNATE AN AREA OF
YOUR CITY YOU GET TO PICK WHERE
IT IS DESIGNATED AREA WHERE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE THIS MASSIVE
MELTDOWN MEGAFIGHT RESULTING IN
LITIGATION EVERYWHERE ELSE
DESIGNATED ZONE. AND WHAT WE'RE
ASKING TODAY IS THAT WHEN YOU
DESIGNATE THAT ZONE. DON'T SPAM
IT. PUT IT SOMEWHERE WHERE YOU
CAN ACTUALLY SIGN A HOMELESS
SHELTER YOU GET TO PICK WHERE.
BUT DON'T PUT IT TWENTY MILES
OUTSIDE OF THE CITY DON'T PUT
IN THE MIDDLE OF A REMOTE
INDUSTRIAL AREA DON'T PUT IT
SOMEWHERE WHERE THERE'S NOT A
SQUARE INCH TO BUILD ANYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO PUT IT SOMEWHERE
WHERE IT IS POSSIBLE. WE HAVE A
SEVERE SHELTER SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE ENTIRE
COUNTIES THAT DO NOT HAVE A
SINGLE SHELTER BED. COUNTIES
THAT ONLY HAVE WINTER SHELTERS.
TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE YOUTH
SPECIFIC HOMELESS SHELTERS AND
SO GUESS WHERE THOSE KIDS ARE
GOING NOT WITH THE ADULTS. BEAR
SO STE AND SOMEWHERE ELSE WHERE
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE. WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
ACTUALLY TAKE A STEP TODAY THIS
ISN'T GOING TO OVERNIGHT SOLVE
THE PROBLEM. BUT THIS WILL HELP
AND TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM FROM
LAKE ELSINORE. YES THE STATE
CAN DO MORE BUT LET'S BE CLEAR
THE STATE DOESN'T MAKE THESE
LAND USE DECISIONS THE STATE
DOESN'T SITE HOMELESS SHELTERS
THAT CITIES AND UNLESS WE HAVE
ACTUAL PARAMETERS AND RULES FOR
THE CITIES TO DO THAT THE
SHELTERS ARE NOT GOING TO GET
CITED AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THIS SHAME. THAT IS WITHIN
OUR STATE RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
ON SHELTER HOMELESSNESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MEMBERS I'M
ASKED TO REMIND ALL OF US TO
KEEP OUR LOVELY FACES COVERED
WHILE WE MAKE OUR PRESENTATION.
ON THAT NOTE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES NO
BELL I FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE
A I QUE NO DALLY. DODD I THERE
ARE SO. I GALGIANI I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG HI
HILL I HUESO OR I TADO. I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL
I MONEY. I MORE LOCK. I MORAL.
NO NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE
STERN I NUMBER I WAY CASKEY. I
WIENER I WILK NO. I'M SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THEM TO MEMBERS.
FOR JUST. NO DALLY. NIELSEN.
RUBIO HOLD. WELCOME TO THE CALL.
CORRECT MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED CENTER
HUESO ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP THAT ITEM HE IS. SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ SENATE BILL
FORTINO THREE BY SENATOR HUESO
AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY.
SOONER OR SO. THANK YOU MADAM
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND-
AND SENATORS I RISE TO PRESENT
AS BE FORTINO THREE THIS IS A
BILL THAT WILL EXPAND THE
INCOME ELIGIBILITY FOR LOW
INCOME ENERGY SAVINGS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. ALSO KNOWN
AS THE S. THE PROGRAM. THE S. A
PROGRAMS ONE OF THE STATE'S
LONGEST STANDING IN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS IT-
PROVIDESNO COST HOME
WEATHERIZATION SERVICES ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES. AND A
MINOR HOME REPAIRS TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES SERVE BY THE
STATE'S FOR LARGEST. ENERGY
UTILITIES THE PROGRAM HELPS TO
CONSERVE ENERGY REDUCE ENERGY
UTILITY BILLS IMPROVE HEALTH
COMFORT AND SAFETY IT SUPPORTS
JOBS AND DISADVANTAGED LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ALL THE
WHILE HELPING TO ADVANCE STATES
CLIMATE GOALS. THE CURRENT
INCOME ELIGIBILITY LIMIT HAS
NOT BEEN ADJUSTED FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS AND FOR THAT REASONS THE
FUNDS THAT ARE COLLECTED TO STE
TO FUND THIS PROGRAM. HAVE BEEN
A MASS SCENE AND GROWING AND
THEY ARE NOT BEING UTILIZED FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY THE
DEFINITION NEEDS TO BE CHANGED
THE ELIGIBILITY NEEDS TO BE
CHANGE THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL.
WOULD DO WE WOULD APPLY THE LOW
INCOME DEFINITION USED AT THE
ANNUAL INCOME LIMITS PUBLISHED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BASED ON THE US
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
GUIDELINES. AND ED BY UTILIZING
THE H. U. D. INCOME LIMITS THE
COST OF LIVING A REGIONAL
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS WILL BE
BETTER FLOOD DID IN THE
ELIGIBILITY WHICH MEANS MORE
PEOPLE QUALIFY WHICH MEANS
THESE FUNDS WILL BE UTILIZED.
AND WHICH MEANS THAT- WE WILL
THAT WILL BE MORE EFFICIENCY IN
OUR ENERGY PROGRAM WHICH MEANS
MORE PEOPLE WILL SAVE MONE.
AND THE STATE WELL LET ME TELL
INVEST LESS. SO WE EXPECT THAT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. ANNUALLY WILL NOW BE
USED AND CREATE AN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND BETTER SERVE OUR
OUR CONSTITUENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. GIVEN THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC- AND A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ECONOMIC
AND RACIAL DISPARITIES IN OUR
COUNTRY. THE URGENCY TO HELP
MORE CALIFORNIANS. ARE MORE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME
POPULATION IS EVEN MORE
PRESSING THAN EVER BY EXPANDING
THE DEFINITION OF LOW INCOME
ELIGIBILITY SB FORTINO THREE
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT MORE
CLIFORNIANS FINANCIALLY
STRUGGLING FAN. AND OF THOSE
WITHIN THE GUIDELINES WILL BE
SERVED AND BENEFIT FROM THE
IMPORTANT PROGRAM BUT NOT ONLY
WILL THEY BE SERVED. REPAIRS
WILL BE SERVED THE ENVIRONMENT
WILL BE SERVED CALIFORNIA WILL
CREATE MORE JOBS AND THOSE
BUSINESSES- THE DEPEND ON THIS-
PROVIDING SERVICE FOR GROW
BEFORE GRAHAM. WILL HAVE OF.
MORE OF AN OPPORTUNITY. TO STAY
IN BUSINESSES AS WELL SO THIS
REALLY HELPS. EVERYBODY ACROSS
THE STATE. MANA AND THIS IS AN
EASY VOTE BECAUSE THIS IS GOOD
FOR BUSINESS GOOD FOR WORKERS
GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT GOOD
FOR OUR ECONOMY AND GOOD FOR A
LOCUM RESIDENTS AND GOOD FOR
EVERYONE THIS PAIN INTO THIS
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE. ARE A PAIR DOLLARS AGO
TO FULFILL ON A GOAL THAT ITS
IMPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYE
BUT THANK YOU MEMBERS. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEN NO MICROPHONES
MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES. BELL FIVE FOR
JUST. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CHIANG. DOLLY DODD I THERE ARE
SO. I GALGIANI. I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG BY
HILL I HUESO OR I TADO. I
JACKSON. I JONES. NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL.
I MONEY I MORE LOCK MORALE. NO
NIELSEN. PAN HI PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER. I WHITE HOUSE
SKI. I WIENER. I WILK HI. NO
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES FOR JUST. CHIANG
DALLY. GROW NO. MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN. PRICE THIRTY KNOWS FOR
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GONNA
LIVE TO CALL ON FILE ITEM
NINETY FOUR MEMBERS WERE
LIFTING THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
NINETY FOUR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TALLY.
NIELSEN. RUBIO I. ARE YOU SEE
THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES. MR MAJORITY LEADER FOR
PURPOSE. UNDER A MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MISTER PRESIDENT
REMOVING BACK TO MOTIONS ARE
RATHER THAN POLLUTION STE THANK
YOU THREE MATTERS FIRST-
THERE'S A RESOLUTION OF THE
DEATHS REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING A
CA FIVE AND SIX TO BE HEARD AND
REPORTED BY THE COMMITTEE THESE
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. FOR YAMS CONSENT
ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ TO
RESOLUTION. RESOLVED AT THAT
JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE BE
DISPENSED WITH. THANKS BUT
SENATOR GROVE I'M SORRY. THE
ROLL CALL VOTE I'M SORRY
OBJECTING REQUEST A ROLL CALL
VOTE YES THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BELL I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG. NO
DOLLY. NO DODD. HI THERE ASSUME.
I GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROW. NO HERTZBERG HI I HILL.
I HUESO I TADO FIVE JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING I MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN I PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER NINE I LIKE HOW
SKI. I WIENER I WILK. OUR IS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN. JOINT
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. CENTER
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MATTER PRESS MATT MISTER
PRESIDENT EXCUSE ME. ALSO THE
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AS A
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULES SIXTY ONE
AND SIXTY TWO FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ALLOWING ACA FOR AND THEY
SEE ELEVEN TO BE HEARD. AND
REPORTED BY COMMITTEE THESE
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ TO RESOLUTION.
RESOLVED AT THAT JOINT RULES
SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY TO BE
DISPENSED WITH. SENATOR OF
MISTER PRESIDENT I REQUEST THAT
THE- PREVIOUS ROLL CALL VOTE BE
SAYS A USED FOR THIS ROLL CALL
INSTEAD OF GOING THROUGH THE
RECALL OR IF THAT'S NOT
POSSIBLE OF WE OBJECT AND ASK
FOR RECALL BUT- IS THERE
OBJECTION TO SET TO DO MEANING
USING A PREVIOUS ROLL CALL FOR
THIS MEASURE. SEEN NO
OBJECTIONS. TWENTY NINE TEN.
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
SENATOR HERTZBERG ONE MORE-
MISTER PRESIDENT EMOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS I MOVED
MEASURES REPORTED FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THIS
WEEK WILL BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED
ORDERED THE THIRD READING AS
FOR AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE
OBJECTION. SENATOR GROWTH
MISTER PRESIDENT THINKING WE
WOULD ASK FOR THE PREVIOUS ROLL
CALL TO BE USED AGAIN AND THIS
ROLL CALL OR REQUEST RECALL
THE- OBJECT. WE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A PREVIOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS MEASURE HERE.
SHE SEEN ON. SOME OF TWENTY
NINE TEN. SENATE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE THIRTY
THREE POINT ONE JOINT RULE
SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY TWO WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE TO
ME THE REPORT MEASURES DURING
THIS WEEK THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION FALLING BILLS
WITH FOUR MEMBERS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
FORTINO NINE BY SENATOR CAFIERO.
MADAM PROTIUM THE DISTANCE
CLEARER. MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK TODAY AND
CERTAINLY FOR YOUR PATIENCE-
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION WILL BE
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY AT TEN AM THANK
YOU. THIS. SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL ADJOURNED UNTIL
WEDNESDAY AT TEN A. M. WE STAND
ADJOURNED.